Three, two, one, boom. And we're
live. How are you? Come on. I'm good.
I'm pouring coffee in the first seconds.
Perfect chat.
That's the good way to
do it with a cafeteria.
I think it is that you guys named
in a French way. A French Press.
That's what they're called. Is
it called? Well it's called,
I think it's called cafeteria,
but it's probably called a protocol fee,
but that makes sense.
But in that there's a French word for it
that we just ignore him. They did a vet,
a lot of the food, you know,
cause you have um, herbs,
herbs and I used to do this bit of
material, which I really enjoyed saying,
you know, the difference
between British and American.
You say that she said and you say herbs
and we say herbs because there's a
fucking h in it. Right. And I
used to like was the fucking age,
but I thought,
well why as the h dropped off for America?
I think it's because put a lot of French
guys would come over immigration and
they would have done a lot of cooking.
You don't see his face.
You guys know about cooking and they
do the herbs and they cut the h off.
Totally. So I think it was an influence
from that. Probably Julia Child,
Julia Child. She French I
think, wasn't she? She is now.
I mean she's in the French
cooking. Oh right, okay. But
that was her thing. Right.
Yet maybe that if I sit
next to Washington and said,
we will use our herbs with the stuff here
and that we could do the revolutionary
war and then a,
and then you guys are winning and then
then we'll hate each other forever.
You guys also do a lot of weird stuff
where you put like a you in color and you
have a why and tires. What do
you put in the open eye? Res?
Yeah. I think we had, we had
first dibs on the lack of, yeah,
I don't understand what we did
know what you got on the uh,
your guys got on the Mayflower and they
said, okay, we're going to talk like this.
Or they say,
whew,
a lot and we're going to get
put Cara the why in tires.
We're going to invent tires.
Get rid of the one. Yeah,
I just think the U and color and the honor
is a year and honor as well and we've
got it and you've got it out and I think
yours is more logical or honor or not
for Herb's no herbs is that's more
French influenced. I agree. Yeah.
I always wondered because I grew up in
Boston and I always wondered like those
were the first people to
leave England and Europe.
Like what the fuck happened to their
language because they developed the most
disgusting brand of it. Well,
you've got your A's, your bus,
today's which I can't hear a strong Buston
coming out of here. I got rid of it.
All right. I heard myself on television
once when I was like 19 years old.
I was like, Holy Shit, what
is that? Well, you guys had,
or we used to have a
mother, father, brother,
brothers and it's the eye and
we say mother or the father,
sister. We don't have an r at the end of
our mother. By the pharmacist. And you.
Yeah.
We say mother instead of mother
and the rest of America has,
it has a much stronger
and Ireland has that.
That's a very Irish influenced thing.
And for us the eye and when we'd playing,
when I'm playing American,
when I was in, you know,
doing roles like that,
the are was the hardest thing to get hard,
hard tar. I remember friend saying, Hey,
I
was cooking this thing that came out like
a hard hard tar and I thought that is
the one, the practice because that is
just hard, hard tar. We'd call it hard,
hard tone, which is just doesn't sound
the same. You spend a lot of time be,
I've only, the only, the only time I've
ever spent in uh, England is working, uh,
like a little bit of downtime doing
stand up and hang out over there.
But most of it, it's just been
working. Even working for the UFC or,
and I didn't even really get a chance
to really spend time in England.
I'd like to, I'd like to do that just
to Kinda understand you folks. Well,
I a different breed when the, I think at
the base having played 45 countries now,
I think everyone is actually the
same when you get down below a level,
but you know,
if you're going to reach for you,
there's gotta be a number of things
which would make it seem different than
brand names. It will be different
than the sports does. You know,
everyone's sports does it.
Everyone was politicians.
If you have that kind of thing and
underneath it all, it's going to be,
there's going to be more mainstream.
People can be alternative people.
There's going to be,
and the whole spectrum now,
like in the old days it used to be
everything was mainstream then a bit of
alternative. Now we, I
think your country, Michael,
we have a whole spectrum
of what's interests people.
It's much more open in that way.
Yeah, I certainly agree. We,
yeah, it's, the collection
of people is very similar.
It's just they're operating in a different
environment and different theater.
Right. And uh, you know,
we're tightly smashed together.
Would it be 65 million in your 300
million and you're such a large,
your country is so large compared to us.
Um, because there was this thing of Ted,
any temps out of Americans have possibles.
But if you look at it,
something like that. But then if you
look at where the 10% can go in America,
it's just so huge.
So it's slightly more understandable why
a lot of Americans say I don't need a
possible cause. I'm just going
to go to that place, which is,
that's an understanding of
you. But I think, you know,
I think it would do everybody good
to go somewhere like, like Asia,
like a, every time I go to Asia I always
think, okay, people are like this too.
Like this is, this is an interesting
thing to experience in particular,
which I really loved. Right? Thailand is
a, it's amazing because it's like wow,
they might,
they hit like this perfect frequency
where everybody's really friendly and
really nice and it's, it's uh, you know,
they call it the land of the smiles.
It's this very unusual environment there
where everybody seems like warm and
greeting. I don't think I'm wrapped
into one rood tie while I was there.
I that sounds very interesting.
And I, I've, I've, yeah,
when I toured Asia, but unfortunately
it was kind of out in, you know,
but uh,
that's interesting about the ties,
ties more than any other country cause
I shared they must have a black market
and a thing and some gangster of
some title. Very nice gangsters.
Maybe the nicest gangsters we know.
Sure.
They're not ask you first
before they shoot you,
I'm sure when it gets to the drug
smuggling and sex trafficking and all the
other day,
but would mind awfully
polite drugs. Douglas. I mean they,
they have obviously a very
open environment. When
you go do you see Bangkok?
It's like Molly Thai fights and chaos
and a lot of ex pats wandering around
drinking. You know, they're,
it's a different sort of
world over there. But, uh,
when I was there, I was in Chiang Mai
and it's just super friendly people.
Beautiful landscape. Very nice. Have
you been in Vietnam? No. Never heard.
It's amazing though,
but yeah, I mean I find that
from an American perspective,
it'd be very interesting
people going there,
even if they were there before and during
the time of war after just to see how
people are because they
fought for so long.
There's all the French stuff before that,
the chain them,
but even before America
got involved in it,
they call it a thousand year war that
they fought. Anyway, it's interesting. I,
I hope new generations coming along
don't bring the baggage of before,
you know,
previous generations and we can all try
and move forward into a world that smart
positive even though it doesn't
necessarily look like that.
What has always been really interesting
to me about Vietnam that I learned from
Bordain was that they,
they don't hold any grudges towards
Americans, which I find incredible. Aye,
I got that sense of it. I have not
played there, haven't been there,
but I got that sense that
they were looking forward.
They just accept it as the past and they
don't have any grudges and it's like,
it's an amazing attitude.
It is an amazing attitude.
I suppose it's better if you,
they did an empirical,
it's empirical window and they kind of,
they didn't like do a massive
Conga in the end. America left.
And so they got what they were,
I assume the majority of them
were trying to get, you know,
just so they can run it however
they want to run it. But um,
yeah, it's, it's tragic the
things the words are getting to.
I was going to be in the military
when I was a kid. That was one of my,
I wanted to be in special forces and then
you look at me now being a transgender
guy with that. But yeah,
that was where it was.
I know Trump wouldn't have let me in
the forces right now if I were applied
right this second. Um, but
yeah, so I follow everything. I,
I kind of run my life on the
military and that sounds a bit weird.
I run my career in the military thinks
it's quite difficult to, you know,
any career, putting it together.
Kind of weird. What's your next move?
What's you'll, you'll strategizes and
that yell? Yeah, strategy out the Wazoo.
I planned 50 years ahead. Really? Oh yeah.
Well if you think about it, you come out,
I came out as transgender 34 years ago.
That's not the first good thing that an
agent wants to hear. Your transgender,
that's 85 this is such a thing. This
is even now, they would say, okay,
well it's got a little better than
it was for five, 10 millennia.
This a little better now. But it's still
not the hardest ticket that everyone's,
we want transgender guys in here for this,
that the other,
it's not the top of the list.
And I've also got boy mode and girl mode
and I do drama dramatic films in boy
mode.
And then I'm touring and girl mode and
doing standup and I campaign for politics
in go mode. And I just, how do we do that?
I just switch change, you know,
take off heels, flat shoes.
Yeah,
because if you were just talking,
like if you didn't have makeup on and
he didn't have the heels and the nails,
you just seem male. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, it's a, it's,
I think it's genetically and
built. You know, there's some,
I think there's quite a lot
of people maybe who, uh, um,
uh, the way that light they live their
lives. They live their own personality.
They're not particularly male
or female, I feel, but I felt,
I've always felt since I was four or five,
I wanted to express this side of myself.
And it's built in, I think it's genetic.
Um, and if you analyze masculine and
feminine, if you really get down to it,
you see,
it's,
I find it impossible to come up with
anything that was particularly mascot in
particularly feminine,
except for the ability to build muscle
mass is easier for men in event comas.
That's it. But, you know, great
football as soccer players,
men and women in athletics, runners,
men, women, strong character,
men's weak character. Sure. Men
and women, um, mathematicians,
whatever, whatever it is, there's
nothing that you can really say, ah,
that is only good shot with a gun.
Now anyone could do that. It's a,
we're all humans and so, and we get
fixated by the masculine feminine,
where's it's a tiger. If there's tigers
tacking here and trying to kill you,
you don't care. Now is this a girl till
I grow a Bortech, we don't care about it.
And they don't care either the Tigers.
So you've always felt like you gravitated
towards feminine things toward no,
gravitate towards both. I had, I
gravitated towards playing soccer.
I was in the first team for
two years when I was a kid,
was planning to do officer training corps
and then go marines or Paris and then
guns and special forces RSAs which would
be the equivalent of your Delta Force.
Um, and that was a distinct plan and
you're a lot about that. And I thought,
which war they're going to send me
to actually which one? I said me too.
And it could be the idiots that I'm at
school with or send me to the wrong war.
Well, what is very clear? And then after
that, every other wards kind of hazy. Uh,
but there's all this feminine side
girls' side. I'm not sure how to do it.
They articulate even after 34 years,
it's difficult to articulate,
but I wanted to express that. Um, and if
I look more like a woman than I, you know,
it, it would be much
easier. But, um, yeah.
So I decided to do that in 95 when
it wasn't cool. And I go, man,
I've had a lot of fights in the street.
A lot of people screaming abuse at me.
I'm taking a couple of people to
court or just report it and police.
And then we went to court
and uh, yeah, and you fight,
you fight your fights and instead of going
to do a military fighting thing, I've,
I've done,
I said this might be wrong for me to say
this by say I've done special forces,
civilian division,
you know,
finding people that people speak and
outperforming performing four languages.
I've run over 80 marathons. I'm going
into politics next year. And uh,
and yeah, and a k and the
transgender thing is, it's
in a better place than it was
back in [inaudible] 85.
Well,
it certainly now I think because of
probably Caitlyn Jenner and the movement
that you're,
you're seeing to accept people that want
to do whatever and anything you want to
do it is just more, more accepting of
each other that we do seem to be more,
um,
what's the word
begins with a t the more open, more
allowing, there's a word for it,
which is just walked out of my
head, but I mean that word. Um,
but uh,
yeah,
and at the same time people are going
around doing more killings and stuff at
the same and I,
well there's more people.
There's just sheer volume of humor
and the population growth is insane.
It's took us something like 200,000
years to get to 1 million and then it's
taking this, I don't know, six 50 years
to get to seven and a half billion,
which is scary. Yeah. When I was a kid,
I think the United States population
was less than 200 million.
Now it's 300 million and
global was whatever it was.
Now it's seven plus. But border,
yeah, eight. Yeah. So when I came out,
I think it was 6.5 and I think
that's just running away.
And one of the weird things
is if we are having less wars,
if we're getting better health to people,
then more kids are around.
And some people in,
in I suppose lower income backgrounds
and around the world they will say,
well we need to have six kids. Cause
that's what, hmm. You know, for my,
for what I have much money. Yeah. That's
what we do. But as economics get better,
people have less case and that
hopefully that should calm down.
There should be a buttering me.
I think they feel that it would be
a leveling off of the population.
I've read the theory that they believe
that industrialized nations and
Westernized Society, when people
start having two careers, you know,
and then two career households, people
are less likely to have a bunch of kids.
Yeah. So as people do better,
they have less kids. Yeah. Yeah.
So I'm, I'm uh, I, I'm a glass
is two thirds full person.
That's what I feel instead of a glass
is half full, half empty person.
That's so you're optimistic.
I'm a big, I need to do,
I couldn't be here in the hills with the
narrative that I'm planning to do this
and got a film coming out and then I'm
touring the country and then I'm going to
politics as well.
When you first started wearing women's
clothes and dresses and makeup on stage
that people think it was a gimmick, what,
what did they think they did? I did.
I decided not to call
them women's clothes just,
and I just say that I might close,
I would just wear dresses, you know,
like women can wear trousers or pants
and we used to call that men's pants and
that, that patents it. So, um, but yeah,
F I first started talking about it
and not wearing anything. Uh, again,
look kind of boy light and may or like,
and then you were talking about
it like I had the first check.
This is my first ever jerk.
I had this about two years
before I did. I said, look,
you're doing stand up. Um,
so if you're from a minority,
it's kind of a good thing.
So if you in standup terms,
so if you're from a a low ink
come background, you'd say rich people,
so easy for them as you are a woman.
He's a man. Ah Man. If you're
an ethnic background and
say white people, oh that's,
so if you're a white male, middle
class standard, it's useless.
So thank God I'm a transvestite.
That was my first love and everyone
thought he's making jokes about something
that he's not and they wouldn't
believe me and journalists were going,
I don't know why he's doing this
because he's doing pretty well now,
but there's this idea, is this a joke?
So I thought I better wear addresses,
you know, put some makeup on. And
then they said, okay, he's doing this.
He is serious,
but he looks a mess.
It's kind of baby elephant
thing I was doing, okay,
got to get your weight under control.
You could have better haircut and
that and you just got to fail a lot.
And there's a humiliation period.
I mean this is the weird thing about
coming out that it's kind of humiliating.
People say you look at people say
horrible thing. What they say. Uh,
what the fuck is that?
Somebody said to my face right there
as I was walking out of a restaurant,
so I thought that's not very nice. And
you have to be able to deflect it and go,
well, you're obviously a scumbag,
so fuck you man. So I'm mostly men.
Yes. And occasionally women.
Okay. Occasionally women.
But yeah, I mean, you know,
it's low. If people have low, lower
character, there are lesser character.
She's a strong character. And yourself,
you don't care. I live in that live.
What the hell? You know, people, okay.
It doesn't look quite a bit together,
but you know, life's tough enough.
But if you want to put someone down,
you raise your own status by
doing and they will do that.
And so I have stood in the street
and people have unloaded, you know,
swear words ineffective to me and I've
just, I will fuck you in a violent,
violent, I think what?
You'll fuck, fuck you. And,
and it's literally two or three of them
or one of me just screaming at each
other and I just won't back down.
Now, this happened recently,
it was nine months ago.
Someone outside of my house in
London just having a go at me.
So he knew who you were as well.
They did.
They knew exactly what and where I live.
We said, we're going to do your house.
What the hell is this awesome now where
it's because of the way you dress.
Well it was, he added that into it. There
was a, there was an altercation over.
I was just packing my car cause I was
just driving home between my dad and
somebody says, you've got to give
me a ride in your car. I said,
this is just someone heckles me like that
in the street. I just come back with,
you will never have a ride in my car.
I have to give you one. I'll give you.
So that happened.
And then this guy went off and yeah,
this and that and the other one,
it's just screaming at me and so on,
shouting back at him, giving him
word for word and then went, I said,
who is that idiot? And they
said, oh that's this guy.
He's a known, he's a nutter,
you know, he's just, he does
this. I went, all right,
maybe I should mention it because
he said he's going to do my, ah,
I'll mention it to the police. Our
demand two weeks, that same thing.
Who's sharing?
I mean it's the same ticket.
So I stopped right next time I go past
knows where you live. Well, he always did.
He was right in front of the house.
That's always fun, isn't it? Yeah. Well,
and he said, we're going to do your
house when you're away. You know?
So this was the,
that was his opening gambit.
We're going to your
house when you're away.
Yeah. They're letting you know there
are a coward. Yeah. Well it was,
it was a very positive,
he didn't run a PR company.
I think that's kind of terrorism,
right?
They're trying to strike terror in you
when you were away. Well, yeah, that,
well that is, yes. That
is the hatred thing is,
did you think about just going
out there and fucking them up?
I don't think I'm quite,
that I would've liked if I'd gone
through the military thing of a Gulf,
that I would learn how to do that, you
know? And I've never have craft my God,
my shelf up to the thing.
I do need to crab my own self up,
but I haven't got there. So, um,
well I saw w we were talking before and
you were trying to tell me that you were
lazy. I'm like, fuck you. I
saw that thing that you did,
that documentary where you ran a series
of marathons in a row with no training
at all.
And I remember thinking before that had
this opinion of you and the opinion of
you was, you're a funny guy.
You're a funny comedian. Um, you,
you have good stand up.
You obviously work hard at it.
But then I saw that and I was like,
oh, okay, there's something going on.
They're like, yeah, those are the
different kinds of human being,
the kind of human being that could push
themselves into doing that day after day
after day.
And I looked at your feet where your
skin was literally falling off and you're
taping everything up. And, um, that's a,
that's a person that's got,
you have an iron will,
like that's a very unusual will for a
comedian who doesn't really exercise.
Like when you were doing,
I mean, you were, I mean,
you may be exercise a little bit,
but you weren't in shape
now and you decided to run
how many marathons in a way,
which at the UK one was it the first one?
Yeah,
that was 43 and 51 days.
43 marathons in a row in 51
days with no training at a,
definitely. I did have training that six
weeks training. Yeah. Which is not a lot,
but they did, they said that, you know,
sometimes if you weren't a math and you
should train for nine months before that.
And I thought, well, if I'm going
to do 43, that's going to be,
I haven't been training forever. I can't
be bothered with that. So I, but you know,
and this happened in your civil
war in maybe an any wool, uh, I,
I don't kind of somewhat
encyclopedic about you.
Civil war and revolution
motivated World War Two,
but on the spot training,
you know, training as you
go along. That's what I did.
The first 10 math.
It's trains you for the next 33.
What was it like when you go over the
first day though? The first marathon?
Christos. Okay. Fuck. My first day is okay
because, well it's, it's all in your head.
There's a, um, more mental
than it is physical.
And so the first mountain I've heard of
people who are running marathons, run,
walk, staggered, not very
fast. Get it done. Boom.
The second math in his weird cause you
go, I've done one, I'm on the second.
And you can't really rejoice.
You can punch the sky.
You can't put a metal right near there.
You're already,
you've got up at five or six in the
morning and it's mid day and you're,
you're going through your second one and
then he gets to the third one and then
you'll do the fourth one.
And then it was raining and my feet was
shredding and I, the moisture it was,
yes,
it made it too soft and they were rubbing
on the, on the running shoes.
And I didn't know how to,
how do I fix it when I'm actually
wearing on it all the time.
So we started bathing it in surgical
spirit, which you call something else. Um,
it's, it's a, it's a
ethanol, methanol. Anyways,
it's some sort of alcoholic spirit and it,
uh,
it takes the moisture out of your feet.
And um,
so it became like stones. It's
Kinda like which, uh, um, uh,
anyway,
if anyone does have some surgical spear,
if you Google it now you'll see
what it's called in America,
but it's some sort of alcoholic
thing that just removes moisture.
And so it made my feet, my toes,
like little stones and kind of tough.
And actually that got us through.
And then I started and also apparently,
cause I did 27 mountains in 27 days
in South Africa in 2016. And that was,
the temperatures were crazy on that,
but it seems that the body will switch
on a healing property that we've got
Leighton in ourselves that we don't
use and you will heal quicker,
you will heal faster the more you get.
So I got you get stronger and both the
British one and the South African one,
I got stronger as I went on the
first 10 days of the other key thing.
And after that it's kind of easier.
You're used to it.
Your body just adapts and understands
this crazy ass hole is going to do the
crazy also.
And the brain goes,
what kind of math and shall we run today
as opposed to what the are you doing?
What kind of marathon? Yeah, well I
think that's what the brain's doing.
Cause the first day is going, you
got to do what? This marathon,
but I'd be okay the second day,
the way it's going now we're going to s
during another one, third day, fourth day,
fifth day. This is insane. And then
the data and the brain is going, okay,
you're on this kind of cake or
something. I understand. Let's,
let's try a better man.
Don't push it too hard.
You know the brain starts talking to
the body and somehow it levels out round
about Maine.
Then they get surreal marathon,
18 wrath and 23 I remember marathon
31 that was the level of media.
So weird, but it was fun.
And you own the road,
you know a woody Guthrie. This
land is Ireland's Milan, the you,
you become like,
it's your land.
It's like it's everybody's land because
you're running on the roads of this
country. I grew up in. And you feel
that the roads, the fields, the birds,
I didn't listen to any music I wanted.
It's like a safety thing for traffic,
but also you could hit everything
that's going on. Birds,
Chad rivers running there was,
I ran possibly his house.
This isn't that bad day too.
And there was a river running there and
it went through the back of this guy's
garden and he said hello.
And I said,
can I went and visited him and I washed
my feet in the river and then I put the
socks back on and I carried on running.
I thought I can, you can do with these.
I took blackberries out of the
bushes like I did when I was a kid.
It just became effective feral,
this holistic or feral marathons.
That's what I was doing. It's not run,
it's not people shouting from the sides.
No one cares really, which is fine. And
I'm just wrapped up in this other place
and it was beautiful.
I mean it's Zan.
Well it seems like it would change you
like accomplishing something like that.
Like on the last day,
the last run when you crossed the line,
what was that feeling like? Why this
is a pitch. He brought up that picture.
This is me getting the, they put up some
flags and stuff. That was beautiful.
I tried to do a five hour marathon.
Now if you know the speeds,
it's two hours is what they're trying
to break that. So this is really slow.
But then having done 42 marathons,
it's maybe it's fair and uh, I,
I missed it by about 30 seconds,
but it was,
it was beautiful to finish it. I was
really quite strong all the way through.
I didn't stop at any time. That was,
that was good. In South Africa though,
I did 27 and 27 days.
It started a salute to Nelson Mandela
was 27 years in prison and day five,
they put me in the hospital because
they thought my kidneys were giving up.
And you experiencing Rhabdo is that
what it is? You know, but yeah, yeah,
yeah. Your first book ever talked to WHO's
done it about revved my license. Yeah.
I got Rhabdo in 2012.
Um,
and you get that I was on a uh,
anti-cholesterol drug,
just the sort of health drug,
your cholesterol is a bit high tech
this thing once a day and side effect is
rhabdomyolysis,
which I couldn't spell being dyslexic
and I was paying Brown p and,
and uh, did it. There no real pain,
lot of lethargy. I was really tired.
And this is without exercise
you were getting in, uh,
that was on marathon three American force.
So I had trained and
I trained before that.
I'd done some training before that one.
I'm a bit weird with my training,
but yeah, so there wasn't a huge
amount of training before that one,
but a third marathon and I
started paying a bit of Brown.
But this was not through the whole
series of marathons or it was, no, well,
I tried to do South Africa twice,
so 2012 was my first one after day
four on an anti cholesterol drug,
uh, tried to control my cholesterol and
I started borrowing Brian p and then they
said,
you've got to go to a hospital now the
guys that we've got to put fluids through
you,
you have to go see a specialist.
Especially said you can't continue this
27 thing because you have to get all
this stuff out of your system. Otherwise
the kid needs, because the it shreds the,
you know, the shirts, the muscles into
the bloodstream, clogs up kidneys,
kidney failure. Very dangerous. A
lot of fighters get it. Really. Yeah.
I'm a fighter. Died from it. Um,
recently in Boston, Massachusets area.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's apparently something that happens
when fighters overtrain as well.
Like sometimes they're not
doing it scientifically,
so they're not analyzing their heart
rate or heart rate variability and they
don't know that they haven't really
truly recovered and they continue to push
themselves because they
want to prepare harder. Yes,
they have this sort of mental
mindset just train harder and you'll,
you'll be better off.
But that's not necessarily the case of
your body can't physically keep up with
the recovery and sometimes they'll go
into a fight overtrained and then they
wind up getting robbed dough from
the fight. It's happened several
and it's caused a few
deaths. Well, they said this,
you said you Karen Ryan running now in
2012 or you won't make it to 2016 did you
get off that medication? Yeah, I
would think that all that running,
you wouldn't need that medication,
I would have thought. But you know,
they check you out and you say your
class was just at those mother fuckers.
You be on this for the rest of your life.
That stuff's gives a shit out of
me and they'll statens. Yeah, it's,
it goes through a scary place.
But 2016 day five bloods were
looking a bit weird day off.
So Day 27 I did double marathon and
that was kind of an interesting day.
So you run one marathon
last day of your run,
you've only done 25 minutes in
and said it's the day 27 or so.
And when you go through that finishing
the final flag where the WWII,
they should be waving flags, you've got
another marathon to go. And it's just I,
my brain like, oh this is
kinda good, but you got to,
it's 90 k you're going to do
today, ignore it, carry on.
And it was a rough, rough all day. That's
five hours. And then another five hours,
five hours plus a mother, five
hours plus. And it was six.
I took 11 hours and 50 minutes to run
90 K so I didn't double marathon in 11
hours. Tim. That's damn good. Yeah, it was
good enough. And there's, they've got a,
they've got a comrades
marathon in South Africa,
which is 90 [inaudible] and
they've got a 12 hour cutoff.
So I said I will do 90 K in 12 hours.
The double math was 84 and then I did
another six k after I'd finished that last
moment. Must have been orgasmic when you
finished. It must have been incredible.
Finishing the 84 was beautiful year
finish at the steps of Nelson Mandela
stature.
Right.
He was made president and
that was bit of an and rough,
I'd have to speed up in the last
hour because of complications.
So I actually got faster.
If either of you have done a thing where
you're knackered and Mac and said now
go, why'd you have to
speed up? There was a wind,
it was a single sport
relief as doing it for,
so it was raising money and I wanted to
finish inside the camera window there to
window til three 15 South African time.
Police escorts were needed,
certain bits, otherwise you'll get jacked
thing and you won't survive this big.
So I said, can't we just ignore the car
jacking thing now you can't ignore it.
So I said, okay, stop the clock, put
me in the thing, drive me to Pretoria.
Stopped me off. But then I'll run there
and we'll just continue it on there.
So we had to do that.
So we got behind because I wasn't running
cause that'd be driven across this
dangerous period of port point of
road to be dropped to Pretoria.
Then I just had to run the kilometers off.
So they have like a car jack area.
Yeah. They have said there is,
whether it's, it's kind of out there.
There's no one really out there and
you just go along there and they'll,
you know, anything can happen. So, um, my,
my field producer fixer, he was
just saying, we don't do this, just,
you can't go there.
So I said,
well just get me closer to the finishing
line and then I'll just run them.
It doesn't really matter where
I'm running. Now we know,
Pretoria know we need to finish,
I need to just run that distance.
So I ran the distance soft,
but the time had got behind.
So I had to speed up from 7.5 kilometers
an hour to 10 kilometers in there.
So an extra third, the speed
at which was kind of evil. No,
I moaned a lot that day. I just,
I was just a moaning, whining.
Oh God, I got do this. I what I, I
was never considering not doing it.
And I got the, um, the,
the, the live feed to,
to London finished at quarter past and
we got there about 13 minutes pass.
We had about two minutes and they just
caught it before they went off here.
It was like, you know, like a Phil,
you know, it was perfectly designed.
I just knew if I got that probably I
get more money or raise more money and
extra hundred grand because we've,
we've seen this idiot finish.
He's actually doing it either. Um, so that
was beautiful. And then I talked to the,
this very interesting thing because
you know, if you're talking to PR,
it was a press.
I talked to the press after that.
It was a Sunday and so they kept talking.
Normally they say we can't talk anymore.
We've got two minutes.
And then we got to talk to
important people go away.
That's what normally happens if you're
talking to life press and national press.
But I was on the thing and they just kept
talking to me because obviously a slow
news day and nothing was happening.
And they say,
we've got this idiot who's
just run 27 marathons.
And they kept asking me how the question
and what favorite color do you have?
What, what, how, how big are
your legs, your legs? Yeah.
I don't know what they were asking me,
but in the end,
these two interviews I did with national,
I just said, I'm going to go away now.
I got to stop this.
I had to stop my own interview,
which I've never done in my life and I
realize they've just got no one else to
talk to.
Desperate.
Did you notice a big change in public
perception of you once you completed those
marathons? Yeah, the um, yeah,
the certain community and
if you're transgender guy
and you come out of certain
people go, but I, I crossed
into a line of, well,
if you're going to do that and you,
I hate, I know you do some comedy,
you do the drama stuff. We think
you're a bit bonkers and out there,
but fair play.
I've got this sort of,
I got to pass a fair play to
you if you're going to do that.
And I was trying to do selection,
you know SAS, they have selection,
your Delta forces,
Navy Seals,
they all have this thing that can
you just go on and on and on and on.
It's the stamina thing and that was my
civilian selection for my own whatever
civil identification forces. Just
to understand yourself. Yeah,
I know I can go a lot for, I mean coming
out as transgender when you're straight,
I'm straight transgender, so I fancy
women's. I'm, I want to be lesbian.
So if you come out, you could stay in
the closet and I look down the millennia.
If we go back to the ancient
Egyptians and further,
there's probably a lot of guys said, I'm
going to tell anyone about this. I just,
I fancy women.
I just go with it.
I just won't mention this kind of
feelings in my head and I thought I should
mention it because if people sat and
scream at me in the streets, I will,
I will fight that at least
verbally fight that. Or you know,
if they start going for it.
I have had one fight in the
streets and I landed one punch.
I taught myself to write on the
streets because of this. Yeah, yeah.
The guy was was just giving me,
Ooh Tracey,
oh well dressed down and I was,
I've been a street performer
for four years at Covent garden.
So living on the street,
you know,
living that has working on
the streets and you know,
just knew a lot of people going
around and just said, Matt,
you don't have to be like this.
We can all the space enough for everyone
live and let live kept giving me stuff.
He was a bit drunk so he was just going
to stay on that wicked keeps saying it.
And I said, just chill out, chill out.
And then the third time I just said, oh,
just fuck off. And I went, no, I am.
I am loaded load of swear words on him.
And then he swung for me,
which was the handy thing cause that came
up in court and then I swung back and
I landed one punch,
which I was pleased about and I was
doing the wipe on wipe off stuff.
I was doing this blah blocking.
Yeah, for the Jujitsu.
But I taught myself Jujitsu from a book
if you could believe that, which is,
you know,
you'll get these books with the different
moves in and you can't teach yourself
that. But I did judo when
I was six actually as well.
So I liked the idea of doing these things,
but I felt judo was
always at the bigger kid.
You all get in pajamas and the bigger
kit just throws you around a bit.
I can never quite get the hanger.
I couldn't throw the bigger kids.
I could do it now, but I've
never, anyway, yeah, this is
fantastic.
Video online of a very old judo expert in,
I think he's in his seventies or his
eighties and he's working out with these
young men and you see his
mastery of judo as these young,
powerful men try to manipulate him and
throw him around and he effortlessly
watch this, this old man
and he see him, he's very,
very old and he's throwing these guys
around me as a martial arts expert.
These, these men are not doing
this willingly. This is legitimate.
Like even that guy tries to throw him
and this is a black belt who's trying to
throw him,
but he's so good and his,
his use of balance and leverage is so
amazing. He just knows where to be.
Like see how it just throws
himself into a perfect position.
It's really stunning to watch.
And this looks like it was from the 50s
or something like that cause it's really
old blood yet. Does it say, just
has 75 year old judo master.
I mean this is an old man and the
young man is much larger than him.
Significantly like 25% larger than him.
It at least maybe even look up.
He looks at,
he's twice as big as him and he cannot
throw this old man. It's really amazing.
Juno was a beautiful art. Oh, he's going
more and more full on is and these guys,
I got to get this. He's trying, I mean
he knows that this guy's a master,
but it's just look at
that like it's incredible.
I mean the way that guy's body can toss
these people through the air and yet
they are helpless. They can't do anything
to him way that, look at that. Boom.
Three times,
75 years old.
I mean that hurts my hips.
Just looking at that.
Yeah. You, you can have
many different martial arts.
Which ones you Jitsu
and striking martial arts.
My background was in striking,
which is in taekwondo and then eventually
kickboxing and Muay Thai and then I
got really into Jujitsu when I
got older and well and Jujitsu's.
What's the difference in just grappling
choking people? It's like you,
it's not throws like judo.
There are throws in Jujitsu,
but it really comes from judo. It comes
from the ground fighting aspect of Judah,
which is not as emphasized,
but the Brazilians really a really
emphasized it and sort of uh,
they,
they figured out what the best way for
a smaller person defeat a larger person
is through leverage.
And Jujitsu is really the only martial
art that I can think of that works like
you think of a martial art in a
movie like in a Bruce Lee movie.
Like there's all these people and they
were always bigger than Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee fucked him all up. When the
real world, that doesn't usually work,
like the bigger people have such a
giant advantage when it comes to like
striking. Like, you know,
you're never going to see a
like a heavyweight in the UFC.
A fight, a bantamweight fight, a
person who is 135 pounds just wouldn't,
it's just too much of an
advantage and Jujitsu,
it's legitimately possible for hundred
and 40 pound man to strangle a 200 plus
pound man and do it relatively
easily if they're talented.
I, I saw a documentary on Bruce Lee
and he had the way of, no way. Yeah.
Which really pill to me,
I mean that it's,
it's like a philosophy quite a month
from fighting philosophy, but um,
to be so trained up in so many things
that they do not know what you're going to
do.
And I kind of adopted that.
Well,
he had to overcome significant prejudice,
prejudice to adopt that perspective
because when he was studying martial arts,
you were supposed to be loyal to
your style. So if you learn Kung Fu,
you were supposed to be a
Kung Fu man for life. Yeah.
You weren't supposed to also dabble
in boxing and wrestling and all these
different things that
he was interested in.
He was interested in taking what's useful
from all different martial arts and
applying them. So in a sense, he was
really the founder of mixed martial arts,
which you see today in the UK.
They have cage warriors and
the u s has a UFC and you know,
there's this worldwide now the,
the art of mixed martial arts of putting
all the different styles together.
And you can do whatever
you want within the rules.
Now I liked the attitude of that.
I still have a life attitude then.
I mean there's obviously
fighting attitude event and then as the
life attitude of just be prepared for
anything and everything.
Yeah. And be and be like water.
Like that was his other thing.
Just to go round things, move through
things like don't, don't headbutt things.
Figure out what's the best way, what
is the, what's the best, best path?
Well, you know, yeah, I just, um,
I haven't
learned what I say.
I think I'm waiting for someone
to give me a really hard time.
Then I say now I am checking in and I am
learning in my shot, cause I really do.
You live in England so many places and
really here and I'm everywhere because
I'm always touring. I was
touring Andy and filming, so I,
I just keep moving, but yeah, I know.
But it's, you've got to make the time,
especially if you're moving around all the
time, he'd have to line it up. So, okay.
We're going to check in with this
guy in that place. This, yes. And,
and you'd have to take it and like you do,
it's gotta be something that
you're serious as opposed to death.
I didn't want to dabble like,
um, stand up when I'm filming.
I was still do standing at when I'm
filming and if I'm doing standup,
I will think about doing drama,
you know,
drama and comedy that color related
but different. So I keep pushing both.
You've got to keep everything match, fit
for life. And that's all that matters.
I can drop marathons now. I just did
three marathons. I just dropped three man.
I took,
got home from playing Australia,
took the train up to Barack upon tweed
on the Scottish border, ran up to Dunbar,
which is one marathon and went
across to Edinburg. Second Marathon.
Are you running a marathon
with other people or just
not wanting it for yourself?
Just get a backpack, put my
stuff in there. Change of
clothes, wash kit. Off I go,
no backup.
And is this something that started because
of that series of marathons that you
did?
Yeah,
and I want to stay match fit for life
because that's what I noticed that
everyone's a natural, like all
animals in natural animals and the,
there are the wild animals,
which we were and then there
are domesticated animals.
We are self domesticated
but we are actually designed
to be while we're supposed
to be match fit for life.
And I think as time goes on,
you know people get back into
training or whatever they say,
what would that really hurt?
So I backed off.
I think it hurts because
you're not doing it enough.
I'm not sure if this is a pure science,
this is just a feeling for me maybe that
that I need to stay fit and running and
swimming and whatever I'm doing.
And the less I do,
the more the body punishing me if I'm
doing it all the time. If I'm always,
I try and run every morning.
I almost did it this morning but I
had to get up and do stuff today.
But if I miss one then that's kind of
good cause that sort of recovery time.
But I would just do hit training, high
intensity interval training every morning,
and then the ability to just
drop three Matthew's job,
seven marathons in seven
days. You love that. Yeah.
I love to have that in my back
pocket and I don't think that's,
that's not allowed. That's not even a
list of things you're supposed to have,
but I know I can do it now and I can
do it with just a backpack on. Well,
you can do it too,
because you have autonomy.
You can kind of do whatever you
want to do, right? Yeah. In the end.
And you're living when you want to go
make the time. Yeah. But there's also the,
the actual, that's not supposed to be
in the list of what is what humans do.
Right. You don't just go from around
three and three or seven and seven.
And I love that. That's kind of,
that's, that's out there. Well,
there's clearly people that are doing
that. Oh yeah. The speed, everyone,
everything. I'd done everyone that
someone's done boy more than I've done.
And I kind of know that.
I feel that even if I don't know that,
I have one crazy friend,
his name's Cameron Hanes and he's a,
he's actually a famous bow hunter,
but he's also an ultra marathon runner.
And when he prepares for these like big
foot 200 so it's like 200 plus miles of
the mole app to 4,238 miles in the desert.
He runs a marathon a day.
So we run a marathon every day
and then he a full time job.
He's legitimately crazy and you
know, he's, he always does that.
It doesn't take any days
off and he works at to that.
So run a math and they say we're running
them up, got ready at it through early,
early run in the morning,
run at lunch. Running at dawn
is beautiful. It's African.
Sure you're matching the
African that I got coming up.
We worried about something running up
and grabbing Ya. Well I'm that thing.
I wasn't, I mean they, they told me I
supposed to have security high wasn't,
I was kind of cool. That's for
people we worry about people do.
When you were around any, I
was Al animals. I was in a, uh,
the mountain Zebra National Park.
And you know,
if you've ever been in
a safari as they say,
so they tell you to sit in this shot
of shower bank, big open top vehicle.
It's got metal bars over it
and they say the animals,
they know that the shape of that,
they know it's metal and metal doesn't
taste very good. So you'll be fine.
And there's a guy with a gun and you
feel good. But when I went there,
of course they said, well, y'all running
outside near the vehicle. And I thought,
is this right? This is pretty big,
good television. But said, okay,
I'll just stay close with if something's
coming. And they, they did. I said,
what about how the lions during the
lions have eaten yesterday? They're fine.
And they told me, you know, and that's
what lives, they never go for snacks.
Lines are kind of organized like that.
We ate yesterday,
we ripped apart some animal and we don't
need to go and have a bag of crisps.
They knew,
they knew that the line,
they knew where they were
and that they were okay,
but they said the buffalo are around
and they can stamp you to death about,
I didn't know Buffalo. So black
death, they called them really what
they're responsible for so much.
They're not as responsible as hippos.
Hippos are number one, but they,
they fuck a lot of people up man.
They don't take any shit.
And you think about bowls like people
when people try to ride bulls. Yeah.
Like domestic cow bulls.
They're ruthlessly aggressive animals.
You mean they'll fucking throw you
through the air now think of them but wild
and in Africa and fighting
off lions and that's,
that's African buffaloes.
I mean they are for Roche
Roche's animals and that just,
I didn't know what I had to do.
I know that with, um, hippos,
if you come in between their water source,
then they'll just kill you.
They'll fuck you up. I didn't know
what to do to buffalo's weather.
I had to go anywhere near that
until that grabbed my room. Yeah.
If they find you to be a threat at all,
they're just so powerful.
They just just launch you in there.
This is a great video that I was
watching this morning of a lion.
It was trying to take out a small buffalo
and the other one got behind the lion
and launched it through the air. It was
literally flying like 40 feet in the air,
like flipping head over heels.
Cause this the strength of this thing to
take a giant cat and just with its head
she's woo and just flies.
That wasn't the one with the
crocodile in it as well? No, no.
This was one that was on the
side of a dirt road. All right.
Have you had about the crossing
busy go to busy wild on Instagram?
I think that's the, have you heard
about the crocodile? I saw that, yeah.
That's interesting isn't it?
Because I feel that about flow there are
acting like the local townspeople. Yes,
and that the, I think the lines
of the SS and the crocodile is,
is is another, yeah, this
is it. This is the video.
So it looks like the lions attacking
this one. Look at that. Boom. Oh,
it's actually not nearly as
high as I thought it was.
Maybe I'm thinking of another one. Yeah,
that one's pretty good though. I mean,
just to see it do that. Oh,
you know what I'm thinking of?
I'm thinking of relentless enemies.
That's what I'm thinking of. There's a,
there's actually a, um, uh,
a documentary about this one particular
strain of lion that there was a,
apparently the river split sides or the
river changed its path and it turned
this area into an island and the lions
had to adapt because the only thing that
they could eat was buffalo, which
is very difficult to kill. You know,
usually they're eating antelope and other
smaller things that aren't nearly as
dangerous. Right? So these lions
developed, it became far larger.
So the female lions are as large as
a normal male lion and there hulking,
massive muscles and they're just enormous.
It's just enormous strain of lion
that's exclusively eating buffalo.
And there's a whole documentary.
It's a national geographic documentary.
I think it's really good,
but it's just incredible to see these
things walking around and they look
cartoonish still like the hulk.
Okay.
So it's hard to tell. You'd have
to compare them to a regular line,
but there's some images of
these things walking around.
They just look so much larger
than a regular lion because
they just had to adapt.
Yeah.
And I would think that if you're
running around, like if you're running,
you got to think like you're, you look
like something that's trying to get away.
What made running in that park? Yeah, no,
I was right next to the green vehicle.
So the big metal green vehicle was
there and they just said stay close.
So I was one door flip away from,
I just launched myself
into the is open top.
So I would have been in that vehicle
before they got to me, I hope.
Did you hear about the woman from,
she was a,
an editor on the game of Thrones and she
was in one of those parks and she had a
window rolled down and she,
they told her keep your
windows rolled up at all times.
And she was trying to take
better photographs and the
cat reached in and grabbed
her and pulled her out of the,
out of
the vehicle and killed her.
This is the last year.
And then there they're a
dangerous creature. Yeah.
And you're just out there
running with them. Yeah. Well
I they, um, yeah, this is,
I was at a picture of it. Yeah. Oh God.
They have a picture of it happening is in
2015 wasn't really that long ago. Yeah.
Just looked it up yet. That's correct. It
wasn't recently. Um, my fax is terrible.
I was flying, Bro. Look at that though.
That is just so awful that they
actually caught it on camera. Well,
she just thought it was, you know,
she was safe. She's in the car.
I reached in and grabbed her
and pulled her out. Yeah. I, uh,
you're out there running around. I would
have a, there was a guy with a next to
it will be a good shot. He said
he knew how to shoot things. Um,
I,
I played my cards.
Sometimes you play your cards and what
must have been kind of exhilarating too.
There's something about it, right
there was, I was talking to the zebras,
I just, I went up, cause
obviously they were not dangerous.
There's holiday non-dangerous ones.
It was actually the first day and the
bat was about marathon 10 or 11 or
something. And I felt, you know,
once you over the 10 mark and
I've never got there, you know,
if you've done the whole South African
thing and failed and people are tweeting
about me, Eddie is, you know, Africa kick
your ass. You know, you just go with Tia.
This is Africa. We're a
huge fucking constant. Hey,
that's what I say. No Africa. Yeah,
it's a big African because Africa is,
did you tell them, hey man, I was on
medication. My didn't really matter.
They're just not that whining.
So I just had to come back and I've
tried three times to come back and then I
came back and uh, three times. Yeah, I
kept trying. Can we sell it the day that,
can we get back and do the thing?
But no,
we haven't got enough money
to be able to do that.
That won't be able to set up your
cables and then suddenly it's on,
it's on it's own. And I didn't,
I couldn't train again. And uh,
so I thought, let's just go get it
done. And then day five was in hospital.
Day Six was in the hospital as well.
For how off the two thirds of the marathon
on day six I have to go to hospital.
So for what? Um, well, it kept
what happened? Uh, they, my,
my train, my doctor had gone
away, but my train of thought, um,
he thought I just didn't look good.
It was, you know, 35, 38 degrees,
whatever, you know, and I'm
used to, what does that look?
One, oh, sorry. Fahrenheit.
Yeah, I'd say one 10, one
15, somewhere up there.
And um,
I was not used to that.
And so I was, I would've made
it, I feel, but he didn't,
he felt he wanted me to see next week.
So I saw a nephrologist,
I didn't even know what the word meant.
Nephrologist is a kidney expert.
I thought that would be a renal expert.
We know it's a nephrologist
and it's very cool black dude.
And he was the in South Africa and eastern
East London. It's called as the city.
So it's the big place and he's going,
what are you doing? Who are you?
I'm running for Mandela,
what? I do this thing. And,
and uh, he said, it's, it's okay. We've
checked out your kidneys, your right,
your bloods. Uh, it's, it's your
hydration. Hydration is terrible.
So I'm going to put three liters into
and you'll be paying like a horse all
night. And I didn't pay once. So
yeah, that's what you're saying.
You need some hydration and a,
and after that it got better with,
and so day 11, I got into
national, this national park,
so there's no one else there.
Just me and animals and this security
people in whatever with me. And,
uh, it was kind of beautiful. It was
just beautiful. And the sun was great,
a sunset going down and there was a
rainstorm as well in the middle of it,
the more wild animals out there,
I just felt okay. This zen,
weird place of beauty and also
knowing I'm getting stronger,
I'm getting stronger. I've gone
through the barrier. Um, and I also,
because I've written, I've run format
ans then a day off, and then the fifth,
sixth day I ran two thirds or math.
And so I'd run forward two
thirds marathons in six days,
which is not good numbers for your head,
right?
You need five and five or
something in something.
But for two thirds maths in six days,
it just didn't work.
And then I run another
marathon and I said, hang on,
I've got to run a marathon and a third
and get these numbers matching up.
So I caught up the third
marathon then it was always,
so it's day seven and I've run six,
eight mountains in nine days.
It was always one day behind. So I felt
last day I'll do a double math and,
and that'll be good climactic
and of my South African thing.
What, what is going on with your
mind when you're doing this? Because,
okay,
you're not listening to any music in your,
in this sort of meditative state where
you're just left foot, right foot,
left foot, right foot,
breathe in, breathe out.
I'm saying it's kind of Zen,
but it's not in a kind of like I'm
listening to my heartbeat or anything.
It's more like
I just feel,
uh,
it's just some sort of beautiful thing
of maybe cause that's what we used to be
as humans. I maybe I'm reaching
back into some pause memory.
We humans just used to be out on the
plains and we were looking for honey wild
honey or berries or some root stuff.
And then if we could trap something,
we'd kill either. I didn't know what
to, I can't quite work out what it is,
but I just find it beautiful and I do know
that what you're getting vitamin D in,
you're getting stronger from that.
Um, somebody once read my hand,
I never do the hand palm reading,
but I was at a Halloween party and there
was a palm reader. Then I'll try it.
I'm in a good place.
Let's read my hand.
I can't remember what she's said except
you need to get out more easy to cut out
outside. And, and I thought okay,
I always felt that I needed to be bout
back doing stuff. Cause when I was a kid,
I live for soccer, for football. I used to
run like a crazy idea. I love that game.
And then from the age of 12 I went to a
school that didn't play it and I never
played sports. This is one of
my gifts to myself. Accident.
I think from the age of 12 you know,
you're in your teenage years,
your bones really moving and setting.
And at that time I was
hardly doing anything.
So I think my knees have never gone.
People say running in the knees,
my knees are not gone. I got a whole
theory about the, the heel of the foot,
which it should never, you
know, you should, you know,
sprinters are always on your toes.
Curl running should be on the toast.
And I think if the heel hits, that's what
causes the nails just needs to scroll.
I'm a could be wrong. There's
no, no, that's correct.
That's not how people are supposed to run.
That was actually changed by Nike.
They developed a running shoe with a
fat heal and they changed the way people
run. They changed the gate and it's
responsible for a lot of injuries.
I think that I'm noticing the horses,
if you look for the heel of a horse,
it's right up by that bum
cause the, the, the, the toes,
you know the hoof is the toes and then
you go all the way up that leg and right
by the bum is that's the heel. It's
just an enormously long foot and you go,
well that's never going to hit the ground
and a dogs don't eat cat standard.
We are the ones that use this hill thing
obviously initially to for walking to
make us balance when we went from the
chimpanzee. Good real estate agent.
We need to. But even then, I mean
most people if you just give them,
if they're barefoot like children for
example, like one of the things that I,
I was reading this book about barefoot
running and how important it is to
develop this and that.
Most people that have problems from that,
they're really having problems because
their feet don't have strong muscles in
them because of the atrophy.
And the way they were describing a regular
running shoes is essentially like a
cast and that you're,
you're so used to being protected in
this cath that everything's sorted,
just gets mushy. Yeah. Inside of it.
And then you're also striking down on the
heel, which is a very unnatural thing.
And when I watch my kids run,
like my kids will run with me sometimes
and they naturally know to run on the
balls of their feet. That's
how they naturally run. And
when people start running,
he'll first,
that's where all the problems come and
it's just not a normal way for people to
run.
Yeah.
And I was also in initiative in South
Africa running on set and road surfaces
where they'd just dropped instead of
doing a Tom Academ kind of covering, uh,
they had just put rocks,
obviously some Lori had come along.
This truck just dropped rocks out of the
back to sort of hold together the mud
in the rainy times and
very uneven surface. Fay,
how did the foot, and I was, uh,
I was doing these very thin soled
running very thin soled uh, shoes.
What kind of shoes are you running with?
Um,
well I kept changing them now so I could
I, with the vibrams or than the vive. Oh,
barefoot ones. And unless you
were running around barefoot,
we running marathons and barefoot shoes.
Well, initially I was, and then my train,
I, it just got so hard that I chose
to look, you're going to wear these.
And then I left it to them to choose
my physio and he was Olympic level.
So he said, these are going
to be better for that. I,
I prefer you not to be in the, so I said,
okay, you tell me what shoes to wear.
I'll,
I'll take care of the,
but I do remember seeing little South
African children running on the roads next
to me when they call,
hey, we run with you.
And they are completely nothing on their
feet and they can deal with these sharp
rocks. I thought were really sharp. I
was every few steps. Great. Whoa, wow.
And they would just, yeah, and
they would just, uh, they had,
they were laughing and running along
cause they their feed that built up like,
and it's very, this a very, how's that
South Africa? Yeah. It's a weird watch.
This, no, it's kind of fun because I
go right back. I ran with the flags.
That's,
that's a beautiful thing.
And I was running in Eastern Cape
and they're looking at white guy,
white guy doing, and this is very rural
area. So I led say more low motor.
That was in the African National Park.
That was the rain. That was the, um,
they uh, they uh, where the rhinestone
heaven because he thunder and lightning.
But that's the, that's the truck there
on the left. You can see the thing.
And this guy just turned up out
of the blue to track me there.
What did he give you? I just give me a
letter saying thank you for doing stuff,
but I if ran with the flag
and I said Molo to people
and I led us to say,
how are you and in in the Cosa Gosa
this guy seems like he's wearing women's
clothes as well.
Yes,
he's wearing a skirt and I think he's a
transgender guy with less hair than me
and yeah, he's bald, but
he's a transgender guy. Nope.
Do you take hormones or anything or no.
No, but I could, I could transition,
but then I've got this, I've got
these boy genetics going on. I mean,
I really thinks it's genes. I think
they're going to find out how it works,
but I can't prove that at the moment.
But if I transition over then I'll just
be on the other side of this kind of
fence that we give ourselves. And
I've decided, okay, I'm gender fluid.
I'm just going to have like a
superhero boy mode and girl moment.
Like the human torch can go flame
on the flame off. So I'm going,
when do you just do decide? Some
days today I'm boy mode. I can,
but I tend to, uh, uh, do
sort of blocked periods now,
but when I campaign, I mean girl
mobile, I'm doing films, dramatic films,
I've been boy mode. Um, and it's about
the transgender character. Think about it.
Not really, no, but it's easy for me to
be in girl mode because then if I can,
if I can deal with that and you know,
some people stare at you and I have a
confidence now I carry myself with a
certain confidence, they go, oh,
he seems to be quite confident.
So I'll just relax about that and I can,
I can actually,
I can control other people's embarrassment
because if they don't know what to do,
I'd say, hi, how are you? Can
I have a cup of tea? Oh yeah,
we sell to, oh, that's why.
Okay. So I can just relax people
by just chatting to them. Um,
and then boy, it's quite easy for
me to do cause I just, I just,
boy and I scrub up quite well in boy mode.
Do you have,
but you've given thought to transitioning.
Yup. Yeah. Yeah. Um, but, uh,
you know,
the part of me wants to be Steve Mcqueen
in the greatest scale and part of me
wants to be Elizabeth Taylor in looking
like hone in a cat and a WHO's afraid of
Virginia Woolf cat on a hot tin roof,
which I just saw on the plane yesterday.
So these are the two books I go between.
They're going,
well I kind of both of them and
as a kid I thought, you know,
Kinda look more like Clint,
the Steve McQueen.
Cause I kind of fascinated with Steve
McQueen and what he went through to get to
where he was and he was so driven.
I don't know if you know about
this Steve McQueen story,
you know that he was in a film with Paul
Newman and he was like 93rd on the list
of credits somewhere. Someone
up there likes me. If you
watch it, you can see him.
There's a knife fight between pulling
him and Steve Mcqueen and he's like a
heavy, you know, young
thug kind of heavy guy,
but he's just a small player.
And then the second film he's in with
them is towering inferno where they are
equal billing.
And I think Paul Newman is first
and Steve McQueen is higher.
If you look at,
if you look at the names on the poster,
Paul Newman comes in from the left,
so he's name is first and Steve Mcqueen
is on the right but higher than Paul
Newman. That's how they got
equal billing without, you know,
how do you put equal billing if you're
going to start from the reading from the
left, right. But uh, and if you remember
the film they come at it is two,
two guys you say? Yeah. That both decent
guy. Yeah. These are both heroes. Yeah.
That's a funny thing with actors,
right? Billing. Yeah. They want,
they want to make sure that their name
is red first. Well that's, that's,
I mean you've got to have egos
to do these things. I mean,
so many things need an ego to do them
and then hopefully you can switch,
dial your ego down when you come off
state. Some people can't do that. Um,
when it comes to billing state,
if you know about Steve Mcqueen and his
mum was a sort of sometime prostitute
and had met in and out of the House
and his dad was just never there.
And he found himself through a
boy's, a boy's retreat, you know,
cause he was breaking the law and they
sent him off to this place and then they
told him to talk to these kids
that are train wild horses.
And that was one of the first things
he did. And he was just so ambitious.
And then with your Brenner
in, um, in magnificent seven,
because you know,
if you know that film at the beginning,
they've got your brothers, you know,
that feeling well wasn't actually,
don't remember it. Well it's
maximum sentence. A great film says,
got Yule Brenner with his coloring and,
but no habits,
such an amazing look.
And Steve Mcqueen at the beginning,
they go up to boot hill to bury this
Indian guy boot hill and people are not
allowing it.
There's racism in the town and they both
go up and they ride shotgun again to
hear us. But he was, he was Yule Brenner
was the top guy. And, uh, probably see,
well Kiki, you see what you,
you see what Brendan's doing?
You see what his caravan is? Man, God,
he's got all this stuff here and he
just wanted to be the top guy and he got
there and it's, it's a beautiful story.
It doesn't end brilliantly, but you know,
a bullet is great. Great
escape is great. Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy. Steve McQueen
became a race car driver, like,
yeah. Well serious race
card. Yeah, no, he,
he came second and the one
before there's a documentary on,
on the Lamar, the mores, the 24 hour race.
And he, because he didn't race in, uh,
in America,
which was,
I think it was a 12 hours and they came
second with a broken foot. He did it,
you know, and he was just,
he's kind of a force of nature,
but he was also do crazy things. I mean,
really crazy things, which is just not,
we died fairly young to 50.
Then cancer. He was drinking.
Yeah. I Dunno what it was. How you know,
we still don't know why people get cancer.
My mum died when I,
when I was six and she was a nurse
and never smoked and she died of bowel
cancer. I mean, what is, what is that?
Nothing makes sense if you,
unless you put in random into the world.
That's my theory of the
universe to get there. Yeah.
If you put random and it makes
sense stuff to 13.5 billion years,
we've had about 300 years since the
enlightenment and I just think we're lucky
enough to be here.
We've had five great extinctions
and we could have a six or we could look
after ourselves and treat as a people
as you'd like to be treated yourself.
That great rule do unto others
as you'd have done to you,
and that if we did, if we all did that
tomorrow, the world would all work.
Yeah. How do we do that? How do we get
that going? Well, it's better than it was.
Yes, it's better than it was. Even
though it seems kind of hellish.
If anyone's pissed off with politics
at the moment, track yourself back.
If you're going to look at politics
from any time back in history,
it's always been how it's always been
rubbish. It was print all over the place.
And uh, I think, um,
transparency as opposed to, oh,
pasty, if that's the word, you know,
the more transparent things other
more where you can check, hey,
that guy's lying about that, you know,
if we can work out what's the line?
What's not a lie?
That would be really nice.
I didn't know if we could have
light detectors on all the time.
Do I think it's going to be
mine reading, reading? Wow.
I really think that we're going to have
technology within the next 50 years that
allows people to definitively understand
whether or not someone's being honest.
That would, it would make it, um, I, I'm
sure someone could get a bad side of that,
but it's shoring up front. You think
there's a lot of good stuff on that.
Someone could say, this is going to
happen though. I want this to happen.
A lot of people, scams are going to
fall apart. What do you call him?
Ponzi schemes. Ponzi schemes.
Pyramid schemes. Yeah.
A lot of that it's going to
fall apart. Why they called
Ponzi schemes? Ponzi? Yeah,
I think so. There's like a, there's a
bunch of those little terms like for Gazy,
Jeff Ponzi I think for Gazy is one
that people use for fake. It was a,
there was a limousine company that was
writing bad checks for gazy limousine
service and it became like a thing on
the east coast where, Oh, this guy is a,
he's a for gazy cop. That means
you're a fake cop. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
For gazy became a big word.
Charles policy, that dirt bag.
Look at him either. He's
happy. He's about to leave.
[inaudible] walking, go roaring
twenties. Just wrapping paper law.
Do we tell people as you're listing,
please look up Charles
Ponzi on Wikipedia and
yeah. So that's it. And how
did he die? Did he explode?
Hopefully get hit by a meteor.
It'd be nice.
So you are running for something now.
What are you doing? Um, I'm gonna go,
I've said that for nine years.
Quite consistently.
I would like to say that I
was going to run in 2020.
We had set terms in our politics,
like you always had,
you've had a four year,
we arrange it into a five year,
but then we've gone
back to the old system,
which is where the prime minister of
the country can choose when they have an
election and it can be
anywhere up to a day, you know,
the next day after the election or, uh, up
to five years later. So we have no idea.
So prime minister can decide,
you know what,
we'll have another election in two weeks.
Yeah.
And they wouldn't do that for them. But
you know, like we had a general extra 15,
2015 and then 2017 having
been in for only two years.
Um, Theresa May was persuaded
that if you go over lecture now,
you're going to win big.
You can go into tons of extra seats and
then we'll be able to do whatever we
want. But in fact, they lost seats
and they'll actually, so, you know,
sometimes they grab it sometimes.
Um, you go in there. Fourth is it,
there's a traditional thing of going in
the fourth year because if you've got
all the economics going and
everything's pretty good,
okay let's go now we've got 40,
but a year to spare.
But let's go in the fourth
year and we can, uh,
cause we know we're in a good place and
then you have to allow I think six weeks
for an election campaign and,
but yeah, that's, we do that.
I think other countries do that,
but I am sure to America you go,
that sounds crazy. But anyway, that's
what we've been doing for some time.
What are you gonna run for a member
of parliament for some constituency.
It hopefully in England would be my thing
as opposed to United Kingdom because
there's whales and Scotland.
And is this a step?
Are you going to move further along the
line or you are going to eventually that
would be [inaudible] for an NP.
Then I would blend the jacks.
I don't know if you know Glenda Jackson.
She did this well I'll just shots of like,
you know about him cause he went away and
then came back to creative work he was
doing to doing films,
but he went away for seven years.
So I will go away for a period of time.
I put my career to hibernation
and just do politics. Just stupid.
But you have a set period of time
where you're going to do this and then
afterwards you're gonna retire? No,
I would do it. No set period of time.
I just got to go off and
for as long as I can,
as far as it got and then I come back
when I choose to come home. No stand up.
No nothing during that time.
Could do standup.
If you're raising money for charity.
If I'm raising money for the Labour Party,
I party.
I think that would be allowable.
I think my constituency members wouldn't
mind that if I was raising money for
constituency.
Um,
but if I was just doing it for myself
less, well you can write books.
You like to write books and articles.
It's all a bit hazy.
But I'm not sure if you have the same
system in. We have a similar system.
My friend Doug Stan hope was running for
president briefly kind of as a lark and
uh, realize that he really couldn't
do standup because if he did stand up,
he would have to allow equal time for
everyone else who wanted to perform,
who also had some,
like his standup performances were
then thought of as political campaign
performances,
something along those lines.
It was like some weird bullshit that he
was going to have to navigate that he
decided to just get back out of it.
But he was bullshitting the entire time.
It was just doing it for fun. Now I'm
going to do it. I'm going to go in.
I think a lot of moderate
people don't go in.
I consider myself a radical moderate.
I do radicle things with a
moderate message and they're
already done a number of
things like that and my life.
So I'm just going to take that in.
And what's your goal?
My goal is to try and encourage my
country in the world to go in a positive
direction. I think, um,
I've been saying this politically that I
think this is our last century on earth
or it's our first century. I think
the next 80 years is for everything.
We're going to choose everything here.
We're either going to
wipe us off the planet or we're going
to make it a fair world for 7.5 billion
people where you have a
right to have a farewell,
enough democracy and transparency,
enough money to live a life,
to have a family,
not everyone,
not billions of people living
on $1 a day or $2 a day.
So I think we need to get to there
because then immigration raises its head,
your country, my country,
every country in the world.
And that's all people moving around
because they haven't got enough money to
live on or they haven't been to security
because there's a war civil war.
And if we could get beyond that, then a
lot of those problems drop away. So, but,
and going into politics and talking
about a global vision of the future in
whatever it is,
a slightly,
it's very difficult thing to do
because people are going to say, Oh,
you've just asked for that. How is
that helping this, this global vision?
But I just thought we seem to be trying
nineties 30 politics again and uh,
in political area. So I
thought, well, I'm gonna,
I ain't going to look for a vision,
a positive vision of the future.
And I know when I came
out as transgender and 85,
there was no way I could imagine anything.
I didn't know where it was going to go.
I just thought I need to go out
there and he'd to argue those,
discuss at least try and set up a
positive image version, you know,
cause uh, I'm not sure what age you are,
but I think it was 51 if everyone, so,
you know, I'm 57, so remember
the earlier years of our lives,
it was just so out there. Transgender,
you need to talk about it.
There were gay and lesbian
people have with transgender.
It was like some crazy out there and plays
well, what the hell are you on about?
And that was what that was when I came
in the middle of that. It wasn't a,
it wasn't a, an easy
thing, but I just saw I'm,
if I'm not going to do special
forces, I'll do this. Civilians,
there's a hilarious group of choices,
special forces or
transgender, well, I did the,
the civilian special forces to fight on
the streets and argue people and yeah,
and B. And it's all mental,
isn't it? If you're,
if you're in a isn't any way the same
because people are shooting bullets,
a union,
people are dying and getting blown up.
So I know there's a
massive difference there,
but everything in the end
is psychological. And, um,
if I wasn't going to do that,
I'm just gonna try and do this.
And I would take risks in
these areas of, of, you know,
I'll go out and people say things in the
street, whatever they do and do that,
and then I'll run the math itself
going out knowing that you might have
to be in an altercation. Yeah, I,
I was sure that was going to happen.
Teenagers this point and screaming.
Yeah, they're all assholes. Teenage
boys. This get the shit out of me.
And my friend Eric said, it's my friend
Eric Crisp. He said it to me once,
he's like, you know, because uh,
he was dealing with some teenage
boys in his hometown and he was like,
the teenage boys are the most fucking
dangerous animals on the planet because
they have all this testosterone. No one's
really giving them any guidance yet.
They're sort of just out there wild and
they're trying to outdo each other one
up each other, you know, and, and then
they're, they're cruel. They're cruel.
And they also are insecure.
And so one of the ways to combat that
insecurity is to try to make someone else
feel like shit.
It's like
a sort of weird natural instinct
that people have. Well that, that is,
that's what gossip is.
Hatred.
Gossip is mild hatred and
Gus it when you say so,
so they're less that you lower
their standard yellow there, uh,
respect or the value or whatever by
saying something or you can do it as an
action.
And in doing so you raise your own,
I think at least we're not them because
they are shithead. Sure. Less than us.
And that is a,
that has gone on since the dawn of time,
unfortunately.
Well that's where you see the social
currency of today's like shame, climate,
like shaming people for this or that are
attacking people for whatever various
thing to do and trying to get public
shame against people. But they'd be,
especially people that haven't really
done anything wrong with what they're
doing is they're trying to do that to
elevate themselves and they see someone in
the public,
I see someone who's famous or rich and
they're saying that person's a fucking
loser. And you know, sports figures
and perfect example, you know,
like some super athlete and they drop
a ball, you fucking loser. You know,
and they're,
they're doing this to sort of maximize
this sort of this like this downfall,
this,
if they see anything that's going wrong
with that person's life and if they can
accentuate that, pump it up, it's somehow
or another, they think it elevates them.
It actually does the opposite.
It's terrible for them.
It's terrible for everybody.
But they have this natural instinct,
it's competitive instinct to push down
the person they think is elevated to high.
Well I think that leads to the trolling
thing online that if you do from behind
a firewall of no one knows who I am.
And I remember there was
something that we have bank notes,
like your bank notes that had a woman
on the back of one of our bank notes,
the Queensland,
the pictures on the front and then they
change it up every few years and they,
they took the woman who
was on the back of it,
I think it was a 10
pound note or something.
They took her off and they changed it.
And then there was this campaign,
we need to get a w and a woman on the
back of another different motives.
Not gonna be that. And two
people, uh, trolled this,
I think to women saying, you, you should
die to be raped. I mean hellish stuff.
One of them turned out to be a woman
who was actually attacking another wound
that you think or what's going on in
your head? Where's that coming from?
But behind this firewall you can,
you can go to any place of, well,
so it's almost like they don't think that
a person that they're attacking online
is an actual person.
They're not getting the social cues from
them than not looking them in there. I,
yeah, I just think it's a piss poor way
to communicate with people. I don't,
I don't do any communicating
with people online.
I don't go back and forth with people
on Twitter in the back and forth.
I don't comment on things.
I don't know anything.
I S I talked so fucking much as it is
doing this. I'm like, I said enough.
I don't know if you don't know how
I feel about things, Jesus Christ,
if you listen to this God damn
podcast, that's me. All right.
I don't need to comment on other shit.
I definitely don't need to comment in
text form back and forth with the person
and try to explain myself or it's not,
there's no benefit in
it. I used to, when I was doing standup
in the clubs and paypal might shout,
fuck all of you. Oh, so you know from the
front. And I thought, well, you're drunk,
you're an idiot.
What am I don't care.
And I would not think that person
really knows what they're talking about.
So I wouldn't go into a thing. I would
try and destroy them with you, you know,
put them on some stuff.
But that's what's happening online.
If someone's coming to you and I,
and I used to not worry about them before
and suddenly I was worried about it.
I thought, actually I'm,
I'm not worried about it.
Just literally like thousands
and millions of hecklers. Yeah,
that's really what it is. It's a
heckling thing. Some of the, I came up,
the last one I did was something,
I said something and someone says,
Eddie is a fuck you. And I
wrote back, no, fuck you.
It was a very witty response.
That's like five year olds as they
say loser. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
You, he was the loser.
Disconnect. So stupid.
You never really feel good about it.
Even if you get a real good Zinger
on somebody, you're just like,
what am I doing with my life?
Yeah. There was a, uh, yeah,
my dad's bigger than you.
That's what's going on.
And my dad wasn't terribly
tall so I could never use that.
But what does it matter?
It has been. Yeah. And does
that really work for him now?
He keeps bumping into store the ways
when he goes, he's much too tall. My Dad.
And so you're, you guys are
dealing with Brexit, right? Yeah.
We've got a how's that changed the
climate of England? Well, it's made,
it's made of a toxic, very, um, it kind
of like, what's happening over here,
you know, it's all gone polarized. Um,
like with the build the
wall stuff and it's,
it's one side of the other than this,
no one in the middle in a way, if,
if you look at succession and a,
um,
Merican civil war that was
bound to happen at some time.
If you go back to the
constitution, um, 1779,
87, that was what was happening. And
I think once you've European Union,
no one's ever tried from countries
that have hundreds of years of history,
choose to try and lend to live together,
work together some shape or form
this tricky thing we're trying to do.
It's the hardest thing politically that's
ever been done in the history of the
world. Um, and I think,
cause I'm saying the American model with
native American lands and rolling over
manifest destiny, it's a different model.
It's a different way of things happen.
It's a different time as
well. Yeah. Different time.
And native Americans didn't
have this idea of, oh,
we mark this off and we've
registered this land.
So the idea that people are
learning to work together is, um,
it's tricky. At some point someone
was going to say, I think we'd,
we'd like to change this,
or we'd like to move out.
So this fight was bound to
happen. And, uh, so it's,
it's very toxic.
It's,
I'm, I'm not getting too in right at
the center of it because you could just,
you know, probably like
you have a New York, um,
news broadcasts, you can listen to
people talking hours and hours and hours.
And what do you think about,
what do you think of it?
And it doesn't seem to get
anywhere, right? So I worked
out what my worldview is,
this w w view that everyone's got
to have a fair chance in life.
I know that automation
is happening right now.
So there's going to be a whole load of,
uh,
people who won't be able to get jobs
because of the unskilled labor force that
job's going to get automated.
That's going to get tricky.
So the universal wage is probably going
to have to come in the idea of universal
basic income, universal basic, and
whichever one's going to have to get in,
it's not going to be a negative
thing. It's gotta be something. Okay,
then you can go off and you can retrain
or you could live your life. And uh,
and then there's artificial intelligence
parity by 2050 next 30 years.
And that's what is that mean?
We can't even work out what that means.
I think it's gonna get harder before it
gets easier. And so I'm going to just,
I always play the long game. I always
do the long game. So, you know,
I came out and back in 95
and I just thought, well,
hopefully it will get better over time
and now this world up in 2019 and it's
definitely better than it was, but it can
go backwards, forwards, back. But I just,
I'm going to try and shoot for that.
And the,
everyone has a fair chance
in life and as to Brexit,
where that goes when they,
you know, positive, negative,
you know, I'm against it.
So I was just going to find that.
I don't need to think about whether I'm
against it. I just know that I want,
the younger people are coming online to
vote now they're old enough to vote and
they 78% of them want
to be part of Europe.
And the older people who are passing away,
probably 70 80% of them wanted to be
out of here because that's a fear thing.
Immigration, fear of, well there's
the thing, you've got to be,
have to be brave and curious
rather than fearful and suspicious.
And these are the two ways I think
people can go. If we're brave enough,
we can be curious and
say, hi, how are you?
Where are you from and what do you do it?
Can we learn from you?
Can you learn from us? I think that
is the way for humanity to go forward.
Or you can be fearful and suspicious like
what? Hang on, they'll back off outside.
Don't, I don't want to talk to you.
I don't want to know about you.
And that's the fearful and suspicious way.
And I think we have to
be brave and curious,
otherwise we're not going to make it.
So for us in America,
what you're essentially dealing with a
bunch of different countries that speak a
bunch of different languages,
whereas we're dealing with a bunch of
different states that speak the same
language, but it's kind of
doesn't make any difference. Yeah.
It's interesting because I thought
if everyone could get the hang,
because English has become a
Lingua Franca for the world,
hasn't made much difference.
And America shows you can be
completely at loggerheads,
whether you saying the same words or not.
I think if you're not saying the same
words, it's easier for people to say,
who are these people?
We hate them because I can't understand
a single word they're saying that's
easier. It's an easier way to be
xenophobic slash racist on it.
And I've always said a xenophobia is
just a racist where the xylophone check,
which I got to use software to
political situation. Um, but uh,
it's, it doesn't seem to make
the big difference in the end.
We have enough ways of translating
and stuff and you, and,
and most people in most countries
now can reach for English if they
need to. You know, like some people,
I think Putin will always speak in
Russian. Um, any, any leader of a country,
we'll probably use their own language
first and talk to their own country people
first and then they might
throw in something in English
or in an interview. So,
but we can always tend, we can
work out from vibe, you know,
where most people are
standing coming in. So, uh,
well I think that we're probably pretty
close to some form of viable translation
technology. Like you know, Google
had these uh, Google earbuds. Yeah,
you can do on the Google App
without even the air buds.
If you go to Google translate and
you hit the microphone on that,
you can just say hello. Good
afternoon. Was it? And you can,
if it's on the fringe button,
they'll come out in French.
So I haven't done it in the field.
I would like to get out to somewhere
out in the sticks and actually I should
test it out. I'll make
that a, the Google earbuds.
I think the idea is that like if
you were talking to me in French,
it would translate it
instantaneously to English.
You know it's probably a Beta version of
it now or like a clunky version of it,
but ultimately we're going to have
something that allows you to do that.
There's also Google Lens.
You could I use that when I was traveling
or you could take the the camera and
you look at it and they'd translates.
I've foreign languages and to that Song
Google translate the Google translate
verbal one at the moment
does line by line.
So you have to say a line shaver line.
I mean just think about what technologies
existed 20 years ago and how more much
more advanced they are now and then add
that to translation and that exponential
increase.
It's probably going to,
we're probably going to lose a lot of
these barriers of misunderstanding.
It is interesting.
I do think we,
we have created some amazing positive
things going forward and we tend to bank
them and then we don't get a hit
off. Wow. We've got that now.
Like we can make coffee quite easily.
The grinding of Covey isn't so,
but then we just go, okay and then we'll
find something else to piss us off.
So trying to keep ourselves happy cause
when my happy enough and then it's
usually economics where people are
happy enough, there's less racism,
less immigration plugs, there's
less, everything's less.
When everyone's running out of money,
they get pissed off.
I'm totally understandably,
but we need to make the economy of the
world work and then it would be an easier
place. But how do we do that? How do you
make the economy of the world? Yeah, no,
yes, that's an easy line to say and
it's very difficult to work it out.
But I do think as you gradually
learn to live together,
work together as we
gradually come together.
I mean it's like in the European Union,
say in America,
if certain parts of America or
European Union having a tough time,
then money goes to those places.
Having a tough time to try and get them
back on their feet so that they can come
back in and start making enough money to
be able to help other parts. And that's,
that's the idea.
Um,
and that's a logically a model that
should be able to work in the world,
uh, as we, as we head
towards it. Cause you know,
we know that was a terribly
expensive in a lot of people die.
That doesn't seem to get anywhere.
Surely we should have learned this as
we go back. So conk wars of conquest,
I don't think they are
going to happen anymore.
Quite like the idea we're going to invade
this thing like the old empire stuff,
which I think the Nazis did
the last version of that
for an wars of conquest and
now we're being replaced by wars of
defense was of defense or wars that are
hidden behind things. You know,
under some other old specific tents.
We need to, we've come in to defend these
people, but they didn't need defense.
What was Grenada about it?
And it's still that Reagan was doing
and Grenadier failed attempts to control
the natural resources. Well I think
that's what a lot of these are. Yeah.
And you know, and then it's
economic wars. It's supposed to.
And then stopping terrorism in its
tracks and trying to keep these radical
terrorists from taking over
certain countries and strongholds.
But we don't really have
done a good job of that.
When there's a will you need to do that.
And then people in their countries
understandably don't like people dying a
broad and then was a defense.
Do they,
I wonder whether that's kind
of happening and then you know,
there's this thing called a right to
defend the idea that that countries that
are better set up should be able to go
in or should be willing to go in and
defend.
People are having a really tough time
and tried to get the pot politics to work
on that. You know, if someone
is menacing, the sheer,
when Hitler was menacing
within his own country,
no one did anything and that when Stalin
was meant a second its own country now
one, you know, cause about 30 million
dive understanding. But no one went in.
No one said, hey we got a whistle
blowing time to go in and help you just,
we didn't go in, well we don't
even go in for North Korea. I mean,
we're in this weird
position with North Korea.
We have this military dictator who was
clearly oppressing his entire nation and
this strange to see in
2019 the limited internet.
I mean,
they have like an intranet.
They have like their own version of the
Internet where they have a few websites
that you could visit. We've got everybody
locked down and extreme poverty,
extreme hunger, like the, the,
the ones that have escaped
from North Korea. I mean,
if they've had these soldiers and they're
malnourished, they have parasites. It's,
it's an awful,
awful condition this way right now.
And if you see when North
Korea does military maneuvers,
it looks like the Nazis and you thought,
well, that Nazi thing, well, you know,
I don't like the Nazis as tool,
but how did they get all these
people doing that and say,
oh well the North Korea could do it.
Well, hang on, this is just a thing.
If you spend all your time
just marching up and down,
you can make that happen
and Leni Riefenstahl can
go and film it and with low
angles and make it look dramatic.
Make you look fearsome.
Yeah,
but we're,
we're better off globally than we
were during World War II. Right?
The world is better off the world is
better off in the Western world is more
progressive and more open minded.
Since you came out in 1985 versus in
2019 where we're sitting here today,
it's a different world,
different environment. I,
that's why I'm a glass is two thirds full.
I do think we are in a better place.
There is more tolerance. It does go a few
steps forward. One step back and then,
and always you're always going to
have Charlottesville Nazi rallies.
It was going to have like weird pockets
of racism and weird thing where you're
like, I can't fucking believe
this is still happening.
You're going to have a little,
little setbacks.
I didn't know there was
something in Germany,
something like 10,000 people were
wanting to vote for the Nazi by,
or maybe it's more, but you know
that's a country of 80 million,
so let's get the perspectives right.
Certain things happen in there
on television and you go, whoa.
That's obviously why they do them. To
create an outreach, get on television,
and you go, wow, that's, it's all over.
It's happening everywhere. Oh, well no,
there's this small place.
Yeah,
I mean sometimes, well, the
beautiful things that human
beings can do is stunning.
We, you know, we have so many stories
of just amazing things that humans do.
And then you put the horrible things
that we can do that goes on forever.
If there was a god, I don't believe in
a god, but if he did come down, I said,
what did you guys do? Who are these
bastards? And you guys well done you guys,
but who are these better?
Well, I, you know, well,
they've always said the Lord works in
mysterious ways. So like of the world,
I doubt that's fucking mysterious.
Maybe seven. It's the correct,
I think wellbore to was a test for
God because 60 million people died.
And at some point we're saying,
okay,
how many people need to die before you
come and blow whistle and just say, Whoa,
what's the guy with the mustache doing?
Let's get it ready. Get him off the board,
flick him off the board. That was my
test for, for God. And he didn't come.
So I think it's up to us kids. Well, he
didn't come when we mean what they did,
the Nazis did was obviously horrific.
But what we did when we drop nuclear
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
that's pretty fucking horrific as well.
No intervention whatsoever from the
big guy. No, no. He didn't come in.
I mean he didn't catch the bomb and mid
air go and Hank, there's kids down there,
there's women down there.
There's diseases are not soldiers.
I need to say this and I know
I'm not taking the from the,
the Japanese,
I thought the Nazis were fanatics,
but the Japanese at that time
took it even more fanatical.
You know when the last Japanese soldier
surrendered, you know what year that was?
It's like 1980 or
[inaudible] 75 I think it is.
I think you could listen to that one.
You can Google. He was on an island.
I mean that,
I mean,
how fanatical do you need to committed
still 1975 [inaudible] 74 or 75 cents.
Yeah. Okay. I, I, I give up. Well,
they have an amazing warrior culture.
I mean you think we were
talking about martial arts,
a giant percentage including judo and
Jujitsu of martial arts came from this one
island.
They perfected so many different martial
arts and it's more the Japanese than
any other country in
Asia. Well, um, being day,
I think the ties did it best. I think
the ties develop the best striking style.
And then the Japanese developed
the best grappling style.
But the Japanese are known as
more warlike than the tires.
You never had the time or did they used
to in the ties figured out the best way
to gamble on fights. They figured out
the best, most brutal style of fight.
And that is they,
they incorporated a lot of things that
other people didn't with including like
leg kicks and knees and elbows and,
and they fought really often.
Like they would have these,
like to this day they have limb,
Piney Stadium and all these
different stadiums in Bangkok.
They have the stadium
champions and they'll have
matches on a consistent basis.
And so these people are fighting from
the time they're really, really young.
Like they're taking like six and seven
year old boys in there and girls as well.
And they're sending them off to these
tie camps and teaching them how to fight
and then having them fight.
You know they have a hundred
fights by the time they're 16
wow.
Yeah,
it was just with Thailand it's very
strange because they're so friendly.
They're so smiley and friendly.
Yet they developed probably the most
fearsome striking style on the planet.
I can't. And then they've got a,
there's a transgender thinker as well.
That's a lot of that going on.
They've and the Venn diagrams of what's
going on there that they're crossing or
what is intersecting here? So much great
food. I mean they have so much cool shit.
That beautiful environment. It's a weird
placement. Thailand's a weird place.
I love it. Do they feel in apocalypse
now that, cause I think they did well.
Is that in Vietnam? No nerves.
There was some, she sat me down,
but I think that it's some of it in
Vietnam now. They did nothing. Nothing.
It was typically, it was too
close dates. Why was it Thailand?
I bet it took fucking forever. It makes
sense. Philippines. No, that's right.
It was Marcos. Yeah. Cause they,
cause Marcos kept saying what the
aircraft back. I want the helicopters.
The helicopters are coming in and
they piss off somewhere. Isn't funny.
When a Marcos, when that whole
regime went down, all we heard about,
what's the Mel Demarco is shoes.
It's always,
remember the whole thing that the debate
was had a bad time that cause they were
invited to a place that they
didn't know about. All right.
Everybody got my head though.
That's what they lost to it.
That was the only way the back of a
truck they're holding on the street,
the back of a truck go,
okay we're not going to,
why are we playing all these places?
You know,
that's when they started
getting a hold of there.
We're going to do what we want to do
rather than what someone else wants.
So I mean I,
I'm with you in that I am
ridiculously optimistic.
Well that's good. I think that,
I think people, I mean I'm,
I follow Steven Pinker's logic of that.
People will sort of look at the,
the horrible things that
we have today and say, God,
this world is terrible though.
There are definitely terrible aspects,
but this is without doubt the greatest
time ever to be alive that we've ever
seen, at least in recorded human
history. I would agree with that.
I think communication is a
giant part of that. It is.
This is this global a world
which we thought was going
to be beautiful thing and
they're busy. I don't know.
It's a hellish thing. In fact,
it's got beautiful aspects and some
hallux aspects as any invention has.
You know, like Internet, hey, you can
teach someone how to save their life on,
on the Internet. Ah, you can also teach
them how to make a bomb on the event,
you know? So I think this is always
the way, every next step we get,
we will have some positives.
Then we'll hit the all the negatives and
then we'll go back to small positive.
So yeah, I've, I've got to be able to miss
it. Yeah. Well I am an optimistic person.
I otherwise it just wouldn't be here.
But this military aspect that I mentioned,
I'm flipping back to that. But yeah,
I do try and think I need to do this.
I think that's a good thing to do.
Now. I need to do that. If the 10,
nine years I've been saying I'm going
to politics, I'm going next year,
but it might not be a general election.
I try and plan ahead because I can't,
I see if I randomize it and I just
float because a lot of people do. Wow,
this happened and then that happened.
And then I was like,
and that could be a wonderful life.
But I have my river analogy.
If you're canoeing down a river, um, if
you go at the same speed as the river,
it could throw you under rocks.
He could give you a wonderful ride.
It could be anything, but it's up to
the river. Whereas I pedal like crazy.
Sometimes I back pedal like crazy.
I have actively backpedal
against things and sometimes,
usually I'm peddling faster than the
speed of the river to try and guide myself
through them. And you see that
whenever I do these canoeing. Um, well,
anyone driving a boat through for river
I, when I look at human
interactions objective Lee,
part of me has to consider that there's
a possibility that we need all this
negative in order to reinforce the
positive that there is some component of
human life that desires or,
or relies upon negative
things to reinforce positive
things that this yin and
Yang that we exist under, that this, this,
that we see the horrors of war and
horrific poverty and all these terrible
things and the horrible violence.
We see this and it actually serves to
reinforce our desire for positive things
and reinforce and push our society in
a more positive direction. I mean, I'm,
I almost think that this is when we see
national tragedies and shootings and all
these different, terrible,
terrible things, there's,
there's all this fear and
anger and frustration,
but there's also action
and the action might be,
might think there's a lack of action by
politicians are lack of action by the
police or a lack of action by,
you know,
whoever we think should be responsible
for mitigating these horrible situations
that happen. But publicly the, the,
the, the social fabric of the world,
the way people communicate and interact,
I think it reinforces our desire to not
have that happen. It reinforces our,
our understanding of peace and our,
our love of peace.
And I think that these,
these bad things that we see in our world,
they're almost propel us towards a
better world because human beings are
constantly striving for
improvement and innovation.
This is one of the things that we do.
We want things to be better and
bigger and faster and stronger.
And we want our society to be better at
all times. We never say this is good,
let's keep it just the way it is.
We never, we never say that. So my,
my thought is that even this, even what
we were experiencing in this country,
we like it seems at times that were
almost like on the brink of civil war
between the right and the left and people
are lying on both sides and conflating
people's opinions and changing people's
perspectives in order to suit their own
narrative.
That I think that this ultimately all
this angst and you see it from the outside
and you look at it, go,
what the fuck are we doing?
I think it's a natural part of the
way human beings figure out life.
I shall respond to. Sure. Yeah. I,
I think, I think almost the same as you.
I would opt to slightly differently.
I'd noticed that humanity only sometimes
gets going and does things when he's
right up against the wall. You know
somebody that needs these things to go on.
If you took a wellbore to scenario,
we went right to the wire on that and
then suddenly we came back and maybe not
even, it wasn't even the political
will on that. It was just accident.
If the Japanese hadn't bummed,
Paul Havo we wouldn't. You guys,
we wouldn't have had you guys in us
with us for a dealer to all that.
All the, the, the forces and the,
the money and the almonds and the tanks
and the shermans coming in. You know,
we needed that coming in.
And without the Russian people,
we wouldn't have won world war two and
that was, and they were in this agreement.
So I can't quite work out humanity. I do
think positive. I do think the negatives,
you can appreciate the positives.
I do think one thing on,
on the Brexit Brexit thing that's been
going on is a lot of young people are
coming on saying, well, so we're
going to lose all this stuff.
The ability we could travel to Europe
without visas, we can work there,
we could retire there, we can get a
healthcare they're all costs have.
And that sort of thing that we cut off
and we are roaming charges are going to
go out with the old that people
are valuing what they, uh,
they could lose a lot more.
So yeah, the Yin and Yang,
the you can, I think, I think
it's gonna go on this way.
And also some people, ones,
once we get to a good place, I've noticed
that a lot of people will say, okay,
I'm not going to be
politically active anymore.
I'm just going to carry on doing my life.
Other people can sort of things that I've
noticed that people will get activated
to get to a result,
maybe an election result or something
or referendum or whatever it is,
and then they'll, they will just back
off. They get frustrated. They give up.
I said, well, they just
think, well that's done.
That's bagged and in a positive
way maybe and just say,
but now I'm not even going to
pay attention to what's going on,
but things will start
rolling backwards. So, um,
I think we're going to keep
having it like that. Maybe the,
but the percentage of positive
things to negative things,
there's never changed over all the years.
Over the last 10,000 years. It's just,
there's more people in the world doing
more positive things and doing well and
negative things.
Maybe humanity hasn't changed cause
our brain sizes haven't changed.
Even back to the caveman days,
you know,
even back for the last
hundred thousand years,
the size of our brains is not moved.
So we,
if you went back to seven 70,000 years
ago we would still be able to have
conversations like this even though we
wouldn't have the radios and things.
It'd be more on our tribe.
I think I'll try B is better than you
were trying to say. Actually Steve,
I don't know if our tribe
is better than that tribe.
I just think similar than some good
people that drive in this shit has in that
trial we need to maybe
trade with them mall.
We can go to war with them but then we
could die a lot of and surely could die.
And Kenny and Roger Number 22 you know,
cause those conversations were happening
in a slightly different way I think all
the way back and they weren't all
just getting me food. You Nice, good.
Three, five years. It wasn't that. It was
maybe you know, millions of years ago,
but not 700,000 years ago. And really
started speaking a hundred fantasies.
What we've developed since
then. I'm fascinated by us
as human beings because we,
we, uh, we were just another
animal and now we are,
we are kind of amazing animal.
We've repented beautifully.
We landed on the bloody moon.
You guys landed on the moon,
which I as a child thought that we
landed on the moon. But in fact you guys,
I think that way, but they, Apollo
11, they kept it quite open.
I think Michael Collins in the command
module said this is for the world and
there was this kind of feeling and
Neil Armstrong is, it's a nice, yeah,
I grabbed hold of that as a
kid. I was growing up, you
know, a bit younger than me.
Pretty weird thing to think that we went
from not being able to talk to space
travel in a hundred thousand years. I
mean, that's what they think, right?
They think that people didn't have real
language, 100,000 or Fox p two genetic.
Um, I think it's about a hundred thousand
years ago. That's when it came down.
And the first words we said was,
let's go to the moon in 100,000 what's
your name? Jack Kennedy. Okay, Jack.
Good idea. But let's put it on
the back burner for a moment.
What do you think happened
that turned us into this?
Do you ever stop and think about that and,
well,
I don't think it's a bloke
upstairs floating in the
clouds because they used to
live in the clouds and then we flew
through the clouds and then whenever they
mentioned, hey, he's not in the cloud.
So I, it's, it's a randomize the thing,
you know,
I think these like dinosaurs,
165 million years of those
bastards and all they did was eat,
uh, kill eight killed
pool and, and have sex.
That's all it is.
Those four things for 165 million years,
we've had 300 years since
the enlightenment of human
rights and democracy and
stuff like that. If we, if we say
the Great Greeks did a great thing,
but really it's the last 300 years
they had 165 million years of that.
But why did they come along when we
had all these creatures in the sea?
It's suddenly huge ones. Something
happened, something twisted,
randomizing things. It's, I, we,
we maybe we'll never know,
but it has happened and I just don't
think a bloke did it upstairs with a big
beard.
He said,
now is the time that you speak and now
you make handbags and now fight wars with
the MG 42 and now, now, you know,
I just,
I just think it happened and we need
to roll with it and try and make humans
work on this planet because then
we're going to be getting mouse soon.
And you could just say it the future,
if we've got it going a mouse
at some point, the marshals,
cause there we want to vote,
we've got our own marsh and government.
You sure you earthlings,
you know they're going to treat us the
same way Americans treat the British.
Marsha has come back and attack us.
The match is to actually come.
And you could just see that in some sort
of, you know, a, did you turn the light?
Yeah, definitely happy. You know, so I,
I despair about humanity
and I, and I, and I,
I celebrate humanity. I do this thing
actually, which I think is nice.
I'm going to say this, this
is not, because I'm obviously,
I'm doing a tour at the
moment here in the us,
but I'm going to come out of this us
too on the 75th anniversary of d day and
like fly to call. And normally you're
doing a standup tour. Yeah. Big.
It's up to the whole of America.
Are you doing any dates in la? Yeah,
I'm at the Dolby Theater on
the 26th and 29th of June.
Okay. The Adobe, but was the Kodak.
We don't want to come out from 26
or 20 Oh, I'll look at it later.
Yeah, it's all on that [inaudible]
dot com and but I go to,
I go to Normandy 75th
anniversary of d day and I do,
and they fought the battle
of Normandy in German,
obviously on one side and then
French and English on the other side.
And so I do three shows, Jerome
Fisher, 50 minutes in German.
And then I do 50 minutes in English
and then 50 minutes in French.
And then we have a buffet and everyone
hangs out and wheat and I meet everyone
and we all the German speakers,
the French and English speakers.
That is incredible that you're doing
standup in multiple languages. Yeah.
How long did it take you to
learn that? Well, I did school.
I did French at School for eight years.
I did Germans with for two years. So, um,
it's put, it was partly a sort
of low level political thing.
I just thought if I'm an English guy
going to France and doing it in French,
then maybe a French cake go, well fuck
man, I'm going to do it in English.
And now the Germans, the Russians
are doing English, the Spanish,
everyone's going to
English because you can do,
you can have a Holly would
career potentially or be
on television and English.
Um, you can also tour the world in
English. Now you can use it as a,
as a bridging language.
We were talking about Google translate.
I know French kids, French
code, my friend. Yes.
Seen bellows has performed in Helsinki,
in Finland and finish.
Kids have been watching
in the second language,
they'd been watching in English and
listening in English and he's been
performing a French guide
performing in English.
So they met and laughed in
a second language, which I
think is an amazing thing.
But now you could tour the world
that way. So this is the, but anyway,
so I'm going to get a dome and the,
and the, it's a commemoration of, uh,
that the battle happened 75 years ago
and it's a celebration that now we don't
go to war in those
three languages anymore.
And you have different 50
minutes for French, different 50,
exactly the same uh, ideas. Uh,
but the words are all obviously either
German, French. I'll give you an example.
I had, um, I said, Caesar,
I told what Julia sees us,
it sees it to be everything that one
day he would end up as a salad. Okay.
Cause he always wore like guys and he's
now and a French say's that escalate
Jamey imagination. He one day,
imagine [inaudible] on salad.
One day he would finish up as a salad
and German say's that had to Yeager.
Dax did he ever think [inaudible] he
one time as [inaudible] and inverter as
salad end up would have.
So you've got the verb right at the end,
but they still laugh at the same place.
But maybe about half second later split
second later as salad salad end up would
have. So you have to really have a deep
understanding of how to structure the
sentences. It's just practice
really. You know, anything in life.
You could do it. If you were taking
out of here, you, you speak, you did.
It's beginning.
So if they took you and,
and suddenly for some reason you were
had to be in any of the cup. Thailand,
say say somebody dropped a big block of
heroin engineer. Think just as a test,
as a social experiment and they filled
this hole and use Hays is smuggling stuff.
So you have to get a Thai prison. Uh,
this is kind of extreme example. Anyone.
And then you'd,
you'd be learning within one month
you'd have basic sentences going.
Anyone who goes to prison is going
to have sure. Whether, you know,
if you work in a restaurant and
you, any, anywhere you work with,
no one's giving you any English coming in.
You just have to pick up the words and
our survival instincts would pick them up
and then you might have a strong
accent, but you, we, you me, everyone,
we can pick it up. So I just, again,
I can set up this artificial
scenario of I have to do this.
So I had to learn French.
So I started before this show,
this Vonda Boshia which is German
table, um, meaning wonderful.
And I started it in French. So I
jumped. I cause I improvised to work.
I don't write anything.
I just go on and go, hey,
check is what's going on with chickens,
chickens, chicken with a gun. Dangerous.
You don't write your act?
No,
I just improvise it and I sort of workshop
it endlessly until it gets it. Oh,
that's it. And then you
memorize it a, well, I know it
because I said it last time.
Correct. So in French I was just going,
they pull it, pull it. So don't Ya know,
and pull a Donald Trump [inaudible]
shoes and compare things you record and
listen to every show and
never listened to them. Ah,
you record on your phone or do you know
we have a professional setup so with
sometimes not with the laughter mixed in.
I've just been listening back to the
German shows in Berlin and the laughter is
very low in the mix. So I'm saying this
Jackson County, it's anyone laughing. Oh,
so it's just from the microphone.
Yeah, those are the feed there.
But they had another one but
they hadn't mix low. But yeah,
you need to have a second microphone on
the audience and just bring that mix up
or maybe bring it right up
so you're incredibly funny.
But I just found doing it in another
language, it's a positive thing.
It sends out a nice message.
His hands across the water.
Can we laugh and you can you do
them from us and the comedies.
I do sort of Pythonesque Monty
python type surreal comedy.
And so I just need to find that audience
in France. That already is a journey.
That audience in Thailand as the,
you know,
I've played Kathmandu and met our kids
from Kathmandu in New York on the streets.
He said that you immediately and I
said, yeah, where are you from? Uh,
from Katmandu. Wow. Katmandu a kid
on Kathmandu. We didn't hit as well.
I doing, I'm a student, but your English
is good. Yeah, it's pretty good. Yeah.
Well can I do a Gig in
Katmandu do you think so? Yeah.
I think you do a King Kevin do that.
So I said okay.
That was in 2010 took me seven
years. I got the 2017. How was it?
It was good.
Unfortunately the local I
Lester the low, cause they'd
had these couple of earthquakes,
which they, you know,
you tend to think, oh everyone
has earthquakes and, but no,
they hadn't had them for ages and
something that had to a bad earthquake.
So they were getting over that.
So I was mainly aid workers.
Unfortunately I wasn't
there. I can go back, but no,
it was a nice setup.
But I played all through embed
a in Tokyo and I played in uh,
Hong Kong and in Shanghai
and had all the guys from,
cause you have the,
the people from the communist
party come along to check you out.
So I'm not going specifically, you know,
certain things. But anyway, you know,
my stuff is all deliverable
from the comedy. What the
Communist Party, you know,
the Communist Party. Yeah. You know,
cause it's Shanghai mainland
China Hamadie party. No, sorry,
sorry, sorry. Just me
mangling my words. Oh,
so they come and check you out to make
sure you're not violating anything. Yes.
You sit sitting there is,
you're not supposed to go know
whatever. I Dunno. I just,
I wanted to do the cake, so, but, but
it wasn't like I was going to change.
I have weird stuff about Gandalf
talking to butterflies and,
and talking about my ancient
kings like Henry the eighth and,
and William the conqueror and stuff. So
they probably, apparently they stayed,
they stayed, they normally disappear
after a while. But anyway, so it's uh,
it's good to get out. And you
know, you said, as you said,
play the world sees a week to see
it. Travel broadens the mind. Yeah.
I don't play very many play.
I played in Australia and England.
I've done gigs and Stockholm
and Northern Ireland, Dublin,
a few other places in Europe,
but most of the time when I go on vacation
I just go on vacation and just go to
experience it just to have fun.
So just to be there.
So you've have you never
written Irak down? Um,
no I couldn't.
I used to just sketch comedy like,
like Monte Python thing and I wrote those
and then I was doing a street of for
four years and that's very unwritten.
I no, that was very difficult to write.
So it's difficult to actually
develop material for that.
So I did that for four years. So
I got into this thing of, well,
I'll do performing. Like how,
so what would you do? Um, we,
we were double act initially.
Me and my partner rob and we did weird
things like escaping from a wooly jumper.
He just [inaudible] jump around.
I returned to a ski jumper.
Was that Willie Cardigan? We really pull
over. You've got to pull over. Okay. Yeah.
I got a sweater. Yeah. Sweater. Yeah. So
instead of a straight jacket, he said,
we take this Willie's sweat, take a
sweater. Just ridiculous. Ridiculous. Um,
uh, making a bowl of cornflakes
disappear because you ate it. Yeah.
So at its best they go, this is
insane. These guys are crazy.
And they clap when they give us five
pins and what it was, it was, it go,
these people are insane. This
is awful. And they walk away.
Then we did sword fighting.
That was good because I directed
three Musketeers University and uh,
so we were doing,
showing you how to kill someone when
drunk one thing when you do, you know,
all these different moves. So that was
quite fun. Then I went solo and I was
doing escapology from chains and ropes
and then from a five foot unicycle from a
pair of manacles
escapology meaning escape.
Ology asks that all the other
thing is that, what's the apology?
You guys really call it that?
Yeah. What do you call it? Oh,
I don't think it's a name for it. I
never even heard of that. I think it,
Google will tell us there is an escape.
Artists. I know there's escape artists.
Does it exist?
What does it his word?
There's a thing called a skip ology.
Live escape games were all escape
rooms and there's a bunch of them.
I don't know if it's the same thing as
escape room. No, those are escape rooms.
Escapology should be a, a book. An art
form. It sounds like it's not really off.
It's a craft. Well know Houdini
was an artist of that. I was uh,
I was jumping crofting person is
practicing keeping from restraints.
Yeah. Yeah. There you go. Steal
Books. She's battled his bag things.
So I was just skyping from
ropes and chains and you
made a conscious decision to
do this like on the street.
Like this is how you're developing.
That was developing because I couldn't
get my sketch comedy thing wasn't going.
I, there's a thing called the Edinburgh
festival. We have Scotland. Yeah.
You never that one. So I did 12 of those
in the ends right before I took her off.
So I did three doing sketch and
then about four doing street.
But on the street you have this freedom,
know the freedom when things
have worked in a bit and,
and it's really kind of feral.
No one's checking you up.
No one knows what you're doing, you're
just on the street. I was useless at this.
And then I developed a
confidence and gut confidence.
You know that the stomach's
really important. It probably
isn't fighting as well.
There's something that comes out of the,
there's a confidence center
in the stomach. Really? Yeah.
There's something about the stomach
and you look into it with fighting.
I think it's neurons, right? It's like
this is something, everything joins there.
There's something to do
with it. Anyway, I felt,
I developed this confidence
on my own to go and stand on.
If you've ever seen the film,
my fair lady or seen the film of Eliza
Doolittle bat is set on Covent garden.
It's a massive, massive square. Um,
Washington Square Park in New York was
the quick and straightforward in place.
So it's a big open place and I could
stand up that on my own and talk to no one
and build up an audience.
I would set out these tea cozies,
which are little animal tea, cozies
ducks and hamsters with weird things,
things that just look like animals and
put them on the floor and people thought
this guy's crazy and then let's start
talking and there'll be literally no one
there sometimes and I take it afternoon,
I'm going to do a show.
Welcome to the invisible audience.
Very nice to have you here.
And I had this confidence if I just
kept talking a bit like you know in your
post here, you know you can keep
talking. I can and I go on. Yeah,
because of the odd,
some visible people here as well.
This is Dan's Jack and Kenyans and I
would just go on and on until I built up
about 20 people. Then I could start
the show and then we get into it.
And if you're doing an escapology show,
in the end you're going to get out.
You've worked at how to get out.
And so there will be a definite end and
then you can say, now don't go please,
can you give me some money?
So that's how I am my living.
That's the Ninja training of performing
because I learned perform when people
didn't even want to see me.
Cause normally they, they've cut,
they've come into a room and Lisa,
okay, who is this guy? Then I,
but we're in the room so
let's drink a beer and watch.
But if they're on the street, they don't
have to watch. They can just walk up.
And they often did. So
it was a tough, I had it,
I lost all my confidence on the street.
In fact, I, in fact, I, there's a thing,
army does this, you know, break
you down and build you back up.
The marines break you, then build you
back up. And they also in, in, in, uh,
drama school, they break you down
and build, you buy this kind of idea.
I accidentally broke myself down and
built myself back up on the streets of
London. So, wow. It's kind of beautiful.
That's why I was creatively born,
uh, this new version that had this thing.
Okay, we're going to talk about chickens.
How many checkers it take to
change a light bulb? Well,
quite a lot really because you know,
they can't,
unless I had a friend with maybe a dog
has helped them or they could rig up
something. I just waffled on stuff.
And if it didn't hit a punchline,
I didn't care. I just carried
on. It just kept going.
And then the confidence things kind of
gets you through. He just talks for hours.
Um,
so if you release a special and you've,
you've released comedy specials before?
Yeah.
How do you develop new material once
that special it's been released.
I will do work in progress shows.
So which I took from Lily Tomlin who
did a lot of work in progress shares and
then she did her show on Broadway I think.
And I thought,
cause I used to do the old tour and I
used to tutor to it until at the end we'd
film it and then I begin the next to
with the old tour and just keep that
improvising in the show cause
at any improvise on stage.
And I would build up by the end of
the next two will be a different show.
But that didn't seem to work for people
because they said we want to completely
new show. So now I do this WIP
shows, work in progress shows. Um,
and I will go on stage and muck about
just talking about chickens or banners or
do you have a structure when you start,
like say if it's the day
after your specials done and
now you have to work on a
whole new special, you're doing a
work in progress show first. Do you,
how do you develop? We start with my life.
I did it once where I just said, okay,
let's go through my life. And so
when I was a, you may not know this,
but you know I went to, I was living in
Northern Ireland. They were born in Yemen,
I would go through,
so I've done this troll through my life,
I need some sort of structure,
otherwise I'm stuck.
I also found that once
I had recorded the show,
like I lost tour force measure.
I toured for five years because I just
found there were no rules and touring,
I could just keep going back and I did
45 countries so I can just keep on going.
And uh,
and I found those certain things I'd
developed after we'd recorded it that were
interesting and worth keeping. So I said,
okay, well that's not in the old show.
I'm going to pull that and start off
the new show with that little bit,
which is that little piece of
material which is fun about. Um,
and I was trading on a marathon than dog
dogs will woofing at me. Uh, you know,
I ran past the house where a dog was
woofing at me and this is in the show now.
And I suddenly thought
for the first time ever,
because dogs have swift to people
all the beginning of time, I thought,
what is the dog actually trying to say?
If the dog had Fox p two injected into
him so he could suddenly took what would
say to me, what is that Wolf Wolf? Well,
what does that mean? And so it goes into,
he's basically saying assassins assassins.
I here,
I know I'm a dog. It's my job. Get a gun.
Because all dogs are very sure.
You've never heard of an unsure
Joel dragging your life barking.
They're sure they are absolutely
sure that it's assassins.
It's not a postman is not the guy with
a hamster outside assassins are here.
Alarm alarm,
danger will Robinson.
Why have you never written anything down?
Um,
well I found initially I started
to run the right stand up,
but I would go and I was
trying to type it or write it.
So if you go in to a soup,
uh, my, I'm very sorry.
I'm dyslexic,
so I'm the supermarket and there
that I just thought I couldn't,
I couldn't write. I seem to be
foster. If I was just ad libbing it.
So you got a supermarket in this guy
there and you know, and the shorts,
fruit you go in and this fruit,
fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit.
And I found that if I just
did it by finding it with
the words and there's fruit
and some fruit and you supposed
to squeeze it, aren't you?
And so I just think all the
things I could think about fruit.
So why is it fruit there?
Why not toilet paper?
You never go to the supermarket and
toilet paper in there because they'd say,
well that's a poo shot. You know,
you have to go in as a fresh up.
We've got fresh fruit here.
So we are very fresh. Okay?
That's why the fruit fruits right up
front and you've got to squeeze it.
But how much do you squeeze it and how
do you know it's at the right pressure?
Squeeze it and what if it explodes?
So I would just keep chatting.
If it didn't work, you just move
on. And that's how I developed,
uh,
this very conversational star that I have,
which people say it's supposed to be
improvisation. It's nice. It's just, um,
I am, I'm always ready to improvise
at any point. Some people,
if you write a thing, you say, well,
that is how that piece goes and it's
locked in. But if you improvise a thing,
I've noticed, I came up with
this thing of molten material.
When you first create a new
idea and it's it, it's working,
it's very open and live like quicksilver,
like mercury.
And then you can add another bit
and another bit, another bit,
and you can have a bit,
once you put it into shape,
then it becomes locked down and it
becomes like a prayer and you can lose the
joy of it. It becomes a
recitation. And I thought,
so don't ever have it locked down.
Keep it open,
keep it always loose so that every
time you say you're saying it a bit
differently,
and that's the style of developed.
And so I can improvise
at any point in the show.
I can just stop it and go, what
are wolves? Why have we got walls,
walls and other people don't,
you know,
most animals in the world doesn't have
walls, but we've got walls in that. Good.
How's it, you know, when it's raining,
they don't have bulls. They were okay.
Should we have, you know, I just
waffled about walls, isn't it? Okay.
Don't talk about walls.
And I've ever gangs also.
So if I don't get anything out of it,
I get jokes on the way out.
I get laughs on the way out. So if
I'm, if I don't get in the way in,
so that's the technique I've developed.
Now when you say dyslexics,
so if you read something, what
do you see? I really, I see it,
but I get word blindness. We're at
blindness. I just see other words,
long words. I, I couldn't
wrap to my license.
Took me ages to say let alone to spell.
Um,
I just find that I s I sub vocalize.
So in my head I'm going to ask God,
what are you doing here? I will almost
say there. And you know when your kids,
they actually read it out loud
and I'm not reading out loud,
but I'm saying it in my head and other
people that they can do a page, you know,
they do this speed reading and they just,
you shouldn't,
shouldn't and they could just take it
whole pages. It's stunning. I can't,
I don't understand that
either. That's, that's tricky.
So my spelling was Kat with a k ceiling
with an FCA, logical spelling. Um,
my writing is all over the place, bigger
letters, smaller letters, bigger letters.
Um, and they tested me and they said
I'm severely eight to two, eight,
typically dyslexic.
So I,
I have a huge mental map memory.
I can hold a lot of things
in the memory in my head.
So that's just sort of a
permanent distinction like you do,
this is just who you are. There's
no way to fix that, it seems.
So I haven't heard of anyone
coming out of dyslexia and saying,
now I can read much faster. Now I can do
things. I just think it stuck with that.
But it's a,
it means you think sideways.
And I think a lot of creative people
with dyslexia, I think sideways. Yeah.
So you see clouds,
you see a line in the clouds,
you see puff, there's a train going
through the sky, you know, um,
it's, it's a creative thing.
Juxtaposing things on your wall.
You have to juxtapose the thing, which
is they don't lead from one to the other.
That could be fighting right against it
all. Completely bonkers or out of it.
I'm just looking at here in the room, you
know, and, and linking things together.
I think creativity, we're trying
always trying to throw ourselves,
but in comedy by something that's
weird and opposite and funny.
Um, Caesar, you should, you know,
I'm going for the salad line when I said
that sees a deal. I think it's solid.
And then people seems to
make people Africa, I, yeah,
Caesar Salad and this guy was,
he murdered really?
Where did the million goal if people,
you know,
and he ends up as a salad is not a cognac.
Napoleon gets a cognac brandy,
but he's a Samad. What's
that about? So, um, yeah,
this is my dyslexic traits,
but I think you get dealt
these cards when you're born,
whatever genetic cards they are.
And the,
the art of life is to play
your cards as well as you can.
And the art of comedy is to relay
your life in a humorous way very much.
And that's your unique
fingerprint as you know, if,
if we all have experienced say,
well I seem like another comedian,
we'll talk about your own
life and your own perspective.
It's got three different to
the next person. It's because
no two people the same.
Is that what you enjoyed the
most or the standard? Uh,
no dramatic films I probably enjoy the
most because I wanted to do that when I
was a kid, I discovered that films
existed. I broke into Pinewood Studios,
one of our big studios when
I was 15 broken. Yeah. Like,
like illegally. Yeah.
Yeah. Got It. Yeah. Well I,
I was watching a film battle of Britain
and at the end it says filmed on
location in,
in Spain and England at Pinewood Studios.
I've a heath bucks and I was in the 70s
and then remember we didn't have videos,
we couldn't freeze things.
So he's just a scribble things down.
So I was scribbling down stuff
off the end of films and I said,
I promise I have a youth pastor, I've a
heath, what is that? But it was a bucks.
Okay, bucks is short for Buckingham. Sure.
That's a place I have a heath must be
a town. It's a weird name, town, city,
village. There must be a village or town.
So I got a map of the United Kingdom,
which had alphabetically every
town and village and city,
they're going listed alphabetically. And
I went all the way down and the, okay,
that's where it is.
So I took a train from my,
the south coast of England up to London
tube train underground train that to
place called [inaudible] on a bus to
this, this roundabout. And I got off,
I said Pinewood Studios, they said
it's about half a mile down that road.
So I marched down the road and I got to
the big gabled entrance where all the
big stars would come in.
And they went up and they
haven't got this bit worked out.
So her went up and I said, um, I'm gonna,
I'm going to be in films.
Could I come in please?
Which one I'm going to, I'm going to
make, I got to, I want to be an that.
Can I come in?
I just want to do is piss off kid.
Just I need just told me to piss off.
And I thought, no, I've come miles.
This is a big,
so I thought the must be another way in.
So I went up and there was
another entrance that was near it,
but it wasn't the main star enters.
It was just the,
they're kind of more Laurie engines, the
truck entrance, the bringing stuff in.
And I saw people going into that.
There was a drawbridge a bit like
where eagles dare the film anyway,
someone on the gate and some people was
showing them passes and stuff and other
people just walking
in. So I thought, okay,
you've got to have the
confidence to walk in.
So I did the 16 1516 year old confidence
and I just marched in and suddenly I
was thrown and I was in,
I was into Bible study.
So then in a spill or broken the
universal, I broke into, into thing,
he got a career going pretty immediately.
I didn't get nothing goes well
you're 15 and I know his well it was,
you expect what's going to happen. What
was your anticipation? Anticipation was,
as I've said in a piece of
standard that I, cause I,
I had to walk at a certain speed.
If you're moving a certain speed,
I thought no one's going to stop you so
you can't creep around looking. Was this,
cause they said, what are you doing
here? You know, I just thought,
in fact it's kind of loose inside studios
and no one really knows what everyone
else is doing,
so you can actually creep around it a bit.
But I will run a certain
speed and I sort of March.
So I was marching down streets
in Arles and past studios and,
and I was hoping somebody
go, hey, you kid. Yeah. Uh,
we, you your marching around. Yeah,
we're doing the film called
the marching around kids.
Our lead kid has just exploded.
Can you continue my, yeah,
I could watch your aunt.
Can you say words could string a few
words together. Right? How do you relieve,
I marched down to same,
I must say we're done here.
I marched around for two
hours and I marched that and
I've since filled twice or
three times in plywood and they
ain't going to, I want to do.
And whenever you tell him, I go back
and I'm actually filming that guy.
I broke him. Yeah. This is what,
and I just walk at very slow speeds down
streets knowing that anyone could stop
me and I'll go, I'm just filming
around the company. It's, yeah, it's,
um, so I love films and I've
just finished my first film,
six minutes to midnight that I've co
written and produced it. And what does it,
um,
it's a set in a,
just for the beginning of world war two,
the w I,
I grew up this little seaside town like
America has seaside town as well as well
for the old days when people used to go
to seaside towns before they went to the
hot countries and Quebec Ceylon season,
the Hastings,
Brighton and the south coast of Maine
and the 26 schools there for some reason,
26 schools,
it was linked up.
There was an Earl Delaware that
it's set the place up anyway,
one of these things new.
And one of them had young girls,
a German girls who are linked to the
Nazi high command and they were over to
learn English and make
friends and be ambassadors.
And because there was obviously fascism
in Germany and then we'll fascist in
Britain and they were making friends and,
and that was the idea
there was going to be,
Hitler had this idea of linking that
with British and taking everyone on and
which some people in Britain were
forwards and obviously a lot of us were
against. And, uh,
it sat around this girls school and I
was showing the badge, the blazer badge,
or the girls had a blazer and blue blazer
and I had a badge and it has the name
of the school or Augusta Victoria
College Bexhill on sea. And that the top,
it has a British flag and then the Nazi
swastika next to it. And I thought,
holy cow,
I've just never seen those two flags right
next to each other in the same badge.
So I thought there's a film in
that. So we've made a film. Wow.
Judy Dench is in it. Jim Broadbent,
both Oscar winners and myself.
And what would that be released?
Uh,
rolling it out from the end of this
year from a full, as you call it,
autumn form with you.
So your love of acting and creating films,
that's,
that's your primary.
Even Trump stand up.
I do love stand up and I could do stuff
on whenever I worried that trumped is
still word. I know. Isn't it
weird? It's a weird, that must,
he must love that that word exists.
That Trump actually means to one up and
better. I'm not even going to go there.
It's crazy, right? Yeah. It
also means making tricks.
You Trump things and you can make tricks.
Oh really? Yeah. I didn't know that.
We have tricks and cards. And how many
trips have you gone? That was tricky.
Dicky Nixon.
So that's uh,
another person who did one or two
lies and untruth down his, yeah,
he was also a bad guy.
So, uh, anyway, yes, it's,
I love, I do love stand up. I was
never planning to be a stand up.
I was going to be a sketch
comedian comedy. Well,
I was going to be an actor and then I
thought I can't do it. My teenage years,
I had no sexual self confidence.
The transgender thing didn't
play a part in there. I just,
I was playing football to soccer
up until 13, so I was kind of, Hey,
I'm going to run a back guy. I'm
kind of fast athletics, whatever.
Then I go to a school, I'm nothing and
there's no girls here and I can't do this.
And the oil bodies changing all that.
And I just lost all my confidence
and I just thought I can't.
And I was quite small.
So at school it was all about tall kids.
You played at the renowned romantic lead,
small kids,
you're the slave or the
servant. So I thought, okay,
forget this, I'll do comedy.
I do the comedy because I love the comedy.
And Monte Python discovered them.
I thought, okay, I'll do the
darling. I love you. You're
made out of cheese. I have,
my knees are on fire with this. I just
make it rubbish. And I thought, okay,
that's easier. So I did that
and they wouldn't take off
my career, just wouldn't,
you know, left school, dropped out
of university, couldn't get it going.
And by the time he got going
when I was about 30, I thought,
I'm not going to hold onto this comedy
and start doing drum at the same time.
So I've run these parallel things
and I'm going to be on Broadway. Um,
uh, the beginning of the next year. Who's
afraid of Virginia Woolf? Laurie Metcalf.
Oh Wow. Scott Rudin production.
So, oh, interesting. That
was the same movie. Yeah.
Great movie.
As I say,
I'm doing who's afraid of Elizabeth Taylor
and I'm playing Richard Burton and um,
yeah, that, so that's an
amazing production, you know,
performing with Judi Dench and films and
Stephen Frears Film Victoria and Abdul.
Um, so I'm getting great drama roles
now. I've pushed a long time to do that.
But normally if you do comedy, they
won't let you do drive. You did drama,
you don't review committee. It's
sort of breaking down though. Right?
Steve Carell's, Steve [inaudible], he
has, he has moved to if he, if he does,
I'm not sure if he's doing the
companies too much anymore,
but exactly where Steve Kraus gone.
John Lithgow also say he was someone
who was visually dramatic career,
but then you did federal for the sandwich.
You beautiful.
And he was nominated every year and won
two Emmy's and no one had six times.
Just fantastic word. Yeah, I was on
news radio at the same time I was out.
So we're in the same network, right?
Yeah. His stuff was great. Yeah,
it's great actor. I stunning. You know,
you played them Churchill in the crown
with the Churchill of darker side of
church or that people don't know about,
which I knew,
well here's a guy that really has a, a
love of theater, a love of performing.
When when he talks about
it you could see like,
cause it's goosebumps raise and you just,
you could see his,
he gets excited. Yes, I
can absolutely feel that.
I mean he played such a range of Kate,
if you just playing evil,
you just think this guy is so evil
when he's playing the character in,
uh, in the federal for the sun, um,
it's just a beautiful,
I watched it and you can't really,
for some reason you can't.
I couldn't download it in Britain,
but I found a place I could find it.
So I'm on a second.
I've watched every single episode and
now going through the second time.
So it's just beautiful stuff.
So when you're,
you got into standup comedy.
When you first started doing that,
what is the scene like in England?
It was there comedy clubs where you
could go to an open mic night. We were,
how do you,
we were copying you guys.
I think Lenny Bruce set up the
more alternative version cause it,
but I still think in America it's,
it's always stayed kind of mainstream.
But Lenny Bruce was definitely
doing alternative and then
she got a lot of Lenny.
I love that guy.
But yeah,
and I play them on stage and
that was a wonderful thing.
What did you play him in Lenny?
He know the film was from a stage play.
Dustin Hoffman Film. That was a stage
play. Dustin Hoffman was fantastic.
He was so close.
And the guy who plays him in the
marvelous Mrs Maizel is very good as well.
I know. That's very interesting, isn't it?
Because I'm watching that. I'm thinking,
okay, now I've, I've gone
through the clubs myself,
but I did mine in the eighties into
the nineties and that's in the 50s wow.
And I sort of take myself there and
then there's Lenny, then I think he,
I know Lenny and I play
them. I used to diet. Oh God,
that's me looking at that. But
I was, I was doing the standup,
I w I see that, I put
that together. That was,
and I called him to Jesus crisis
of comedy because as a Jewish guy,
he died for us to die for us to
give us the freedom of speech.
He died for freedom of speech because in
the end that will go heroin too. I know,
but the mixture together,
he shouldn't have completely the two.
He made sure that we could say
what we wanted to understand.
The missus Maizel things
makes it a little,
it's a little homogenized like him,
like in even his struggle.
It's almost like it's no big deal.
Are you in the latest season? Is it,
is it three or two?
Three hasn't released yet.
They're filming it right now through both
of them. It's really good. Really. It's,
it's not accurate.
Like historically it's way off the mark.
There's no woman who's talking like that.
Back then it wasn't,
there was no mrs main song.
I really liked it. And uh,
it's interesting sheet. Yeah. Like
norm McDonald got mad about it.
He's like, Hey, I was, there was
no woman like that back then.
They would say that she, there's no,
it doesn't, I mean, can we give it to,
if it's a fucking show man,
the hawks, not really either.
There's no guy will becomes the hawk now.
I enjoy it.
I really like normally talking, but I love
him. Yeah, I didn't have, there was a,
she was swearing like a,
like a soldier on stage very quickly,
very quickly.
Which that was I found,
I don't know how she ramped into that
and then she dropped out of it. It was,
that was something was bad and then she
went to France and I want to just start
and did stand up. There's someone was
translating and like that was weird.
I have done it in French and I
don't think I could've got that.
I didn't know why that, that seems
just seem to be slightly shocked,
not jumping a shark going up to the
shock shark, swimming around chefs,
artistic interpretation. They,
they, they, it wasn't realistic,
but it was still,
it was,
and that's a person who makes
a living doing standup comedy.
I was willing to let that suspension of
disbelief taste. And I like the, the,
the sexual relationship
is always coming back.
The husband's almost coming back into
the frame and his and his fight that,
um, cause yeah, but no, I, I
did watch a binge watch all,
that's what I'm doing there.
I just sit down and I just watched
everything and then I moved on. Um,
but uh, yeah, Lenny um,
how do we get them to,
Lenny was talking about something
else, but anyway, no, it was great.
It was great playing Lenny but oh yes,
I was,
I was doing the standups and I was
just told by Director Peter Hall,
I'll leave the standup to you.
So I had no direction on it,
so I just did it as close as I could
to how Lenny would have done it.
Did you listen to a lot of recordings?
I did that.
That was very difficult for British.
Uh,
kids are maybe math and kids of today to
know cause he's doing a lot of hipster
references. A lot of, you know, the
Sophie Tucker references and there's a,
there's a Lawrence Welk. Is it the Welsh
Welsh, yeah. We don't know those guys.
So when he was doing it, cause there's
Sophie Tucker and the guy, I can look up.
So for that I'd have to look up some of
the punchlines or none of that number of
the references cause you without
the references you can't get it.
This is a trick I do in universal humor
that I take either huge references or
explained my references so that you know,
uh,
sees everyone probably knows about season
if they don't. Well I yeah. Anyway,
good as Lenny was. It's really hard for
people to listen to that comedy today.
It doesn't necessarily trends,
it doesn't transfer well he's talking
about Nixon and you're going, oh Nixon,
Nixon knows this is a vice president
Nixon and this is Eisenhower, Nixon,
different thing. Um, so he,
I worked out that all the,
all my stuff is non datable is no,
I didn't do any topical stuff.
I don't do party political stuff.
So it should not date. I do historical
stuff cause that never takes, you know,
sees it. It's not going to come back.
Now sees this changed his whole thing.
He's much nicer though. He's come back
from the dead and he's cleaned up his act.
Um, so I've, I've tried to do that and
python did this as well. You do stuff,
it just doesn't really date. Most of it
doesn't date, which is a handy thing.
So yeah. But I did watch stand
up does, and it's also the, the,
the,
the culture is so significantly different
between the late fifties and sixties
where Lenny Bruce was sort of starting
out and making his mark versus today.
It's like the things that
were naughty back then,
the things that he could say that were
controversial, there were nothing today.
They're the,
literally it's a non controversy whether
those one that that still was was when
he said how many people using the n word,
the n ass working,
they just went to all the, how many are
in the [inaudible]? How many of the way?
And then I did this,
I used to do that on stage every night.
And that was still a striking
dance. Yeah. Yeah. But the,
the sentiment behind it was that these
words only have power because it cause we
give them and if he could use
him again, again, again, yeah.
And for the gay community,
they taking the word queer reclaimed that
so it doesn't have the force anymore.
And that that is the
truth. He spoke, he was at,
that was a true analysis that
he did. Yeah, it was, um,
we had some still Joe,
there was a,
unfortunately accidentally a friend of
mine stole one of his jokes and didn't
know the,
he actually just thought of the
same premise. Yeah. And he was the,
the premise was that uh,
homosexuality in some places illegal.
And what do they do if they catch you
while they lock you up in jail with a
bunch of men who want to have sex with
you? Like in that was Lenny Bruce's line.
Like Digg, homosexuality is
illegal. Right. So what are they,
do they put you in jail with a bunch of
men will have sex with you? You know,
like that was his whole like, and like
that still would work today. Like,
if there was a place where homosexuality
was illegal today and you did that joke,
it's a good joke. It's like set up
punchline. It's all right there. Yeah.
Lenny was ahead of it and you know,
he's early stuff was more mainstream
than you can ever believe doing way,
way mate. Same as Carlin. If you
listen to Carlin's really stuff. Yeah,
I've heard of, yes. I
think God, it was like,
like just like a typical Jack Paar tonight
show set and it was all like really
like down the middle,
squeaky clean and he wore
suits and he was a clean cut.
You're seeing Carl in the early days.
I think I've seen once. I, I, yeah,
I do know there was, it wasn't, there was
his tie and a suit. There was a change.
Well, Glenn, he had a complete change
and that thing in the film where he says,
you'll never play here. And what's the
area in upstate New York? Catskills.
The Catskills. Yeah. Um, I remember
when I watched it first I thought, oh,
that's a terrible thing to have.
But now that I know what that was,
it was a certain belt of,
you know how you're going to put out,
that's George Carlin
play a little bit of this.
It's crazy from the Merv Griffin show,
big hassle.
We never see how the Indians prepare.
Oh awful.
That suit is just because
they started defending Malibu
[inaudible]
but is that sort of style,
you know, he had that,
I mean that's what you did back then.
This is the Merv Griffin show.
I mean it really didn't have any options.
That's how you perform.
Otherwise they wouldn't let you on.
What she did change on a dime did he
arrested a bunch of times, you know,
and he became a marijuana enthusiasts
and the, you know, it started,
it just the, the, the,
the times changed and I think you can
only sit back and observe for so long
before you start commenting on things.
And then he shifted and he became,
and I think he was also
experiencing prior,
like prior of course was I think
Lenny Bruce was the original. Yeah.
But prior was the one who made it
insanely personal and it was insanely
vulnerable on stage and also he had a
point to a lot of the things he was doing.
I mean I think if there's a great,
I don't think there's a greatest
standup of all time, but if there is,
it might be prior. You know, that he just,
he had this perspective that was
just wholly individually like holy,
it's up 10
years later.
That's why it looks six bid really does
change at the end that I have been here.
Yeah.
I mean he was looking at him,
he's got a look fucking Steve
jobs outfit on now. Yeah.
He became, it became a, you know,
they hippie hair got longer.
I have a bear. Um, Richard Pryor,
I think Richard Pryor is for
me. He was, cause I had this,
I had this base of, of uh, Monte
Python, which is what I was going to do.
And then I had Richard Pryor and
Billy Connolly, Scottish comedian,
British economy, those
two, Billy talks too,
just so relaxed with talking the large
groups of people and what Richard was
doing. It was the acting out
of all the characters thing.
That was the wonderful thing.
That's what I do. Well,
you're going to do and
why we did it was a no.
The dog says the dog is doses. Come on
in. Hey, come on in to burglars. Yeah,
you called me.
You shall not leave.
Dobermans playing these,
these different voices and characters
and what he could do and that was just,
that was stunning to me. Yeah.
He was something special.
Look at him back in there too. That's
literally him like on the wall back there.
A mugshot. That's the same era. It could
be. That could have been that night.
Yeah. Might happen that night. There's
some fantastic recordings that,
I don't know where they are now,
but they used to be able to buy them.
I bought them on a truck stop and there
were from Red Foxx comedy club and they
were cassette tapes and a,
I was on,
I was doing a road gig
and I think I found them.
I bought a bunch of them
and these recordings where
they just said set up a tape
recorder and he was doing these random
sets at Red Fox is comedy club and it was
a lot of experimenting,
a lot of ad libbing,
a lot of me clearly high on stage.
I mean he would get go on state high a
lot and it was just ramble about stuff
and they would,
you would see these bits forming and
coming out of that and then some of those
bits eventually would be on
some of his more famous albums.
It was great. Great stuff. Just to see
this guy who was just, so, if you go,
if you go from,
you know,
your traditional standup comedian from
1960 like you were seeing George Carlin
onstage to what prior was doing in the
70s it's is so different, so radically,
radically different.
And he took it to a different place or we,
you were talking about the scene
in Britain were interesting.
We don't really have much of
a film industry if we don't
have it as quite set up.
You know, obviously it's huge. And
in America compared to what we are.
We have a quite a good TV industry.
So,
but we toured like crazy.
Um,
so there's lots of tours in a hundred
seats, 500 a thousand seaters,
thousand five,
2000 CFUs that goes on like
endlessly all the time,
way more than it used to
before. So, and there's,
there's lots of clubs and they will,
a lot of them would just
room above a pub type clubs.
So I believe the clubs in America,
which
much more set up there was a bar thing,
system people come out and
do the drinks and, and,
and it was quite a cash outlay had to
get this club going. And it would be,
you know, most nights of the week
we'd have it one night a week,
it just be a function room in a pub that
existed for maybe hundreds and hundreds
of years because all these puppies to
be taverns drinking and it wasn't used.
And they sit there, some guy would
say, hey, I'll run a club up here.
I'll take the door money. You take
the bar money. And that was the deal.
So a lot of amateurs running it.
So we had lots of club.
We had that 60 70 80 clubs in London.
You could, you could zip around.
Yeah. It was a ridiculous amount. And so
for me, what the Beatles had with the,
with playing in Germany,
I had with London and we'll have
with playing in London, you could,
you could do four in a night,
five, four foreign a night, quite,
quite easily on the Friday and Saturday.
You just jumped in taxis and zip between
different gangs they do in New York.
Yeah. Yeah. But it was just so many
clubs. Oh Wow. So it was beautiful.
I think there's less now,
but it's a,
there's lots of open Mike nights now and
so many people wanted to get into it.
You can create, there's no top
to the Korea now. We playing,
people are playing an arena.
I started doing arena tours.
I'm now doing more theaters on this one.
My audience has got a bit older.
But anyway, jumping between the two, like
playing Hollywood bowl here, I, you know,
in La that's such a beautiful thing to
play. And it's the Greeks got it right.
The loft of rolls down the hill, played
it twice now and it's just gorgeous.
I've never played there,
but I've been there for a few
times for a few different things.
I saw Annie there and I
saw the, what is it? Oh
a nightmare. Before Halloween. Yeah.
You so Annie the musical. Yeah, they do
the musical there, do a version of it.
And they do a, the nightmare
before Halloween where they play,
they play the movie and then they have
a symphony and the symphony and didn't
think Annie B you'll kind of have kids.
Do you needed to say that?
Cause I just didn't enjoy it. All right.
I'm bored out of my fucking mind. No,
I was just going to leave with that.
And he's your kind of, I always,
it always comes in. Yeah.
Well I like everything.
I like a lot of things that you would
think you wouldn't like, you know that uh,
for the people of la
or people at the world,
I believe that the
Hollywood bowl is a la park,
so you can actually go up there and
have you sandwiches anytime you want,
which is a beautiful thing.
I do that.
I can drive up there cause it
looks like don't come in here.
There's barriers and stuff, but now
you can pack up and go and it's a park.
It's still a park. I love
that space. It's just got,
and I knew that Monty python and played
there so I thought I couldn't play well.
It's beautiful too because
it's all outdoors and you know,
La has such amazing weather
and you look around,
you see the houses and the
distance and it's like this,
it's a special little spot.
It's beautiful. I don't,
Dave Chappelle's done some gigs there.
I think Chris rock did a gig there.
That's a must be a fun place to
perform too. It's just, it works.
That amphitheater thing,
I think it was the Greek democracy
and empathy others and uh,
yeah. Do you still go to
clubs all, I don't so much.
I was reading the definitive
thing on Robin Williams and Harry,
he would jump into clubs and do
stuff and go on. And I, I it doesn't,
that doesn't really work for my stuff.
I tend to get a small,
I can divert club like for the work in
progress shows I was doing, I was taking,
I was, they, they uh, they
have the Al Marri Club in uh,
in isn't to know angel in London,
sort of north, northeast Linda.
And uh, they had, you know, show going on
at six one at seven and eight, you know,
and I would take an hour of that and just
do that again, again and again. So I'll,
I'll take an hour and I'll go out for
an hour and workshop to show and as
opposed to coming on doing 15
minutes on a, off the top of my head,
cause I find that if I,
if I'm completely going scatter gun,
just trying to find funny,
that doesn't really help me.
I need to keep crafting this stuff
cause then I can use on the show. Yeah.
I also don't need, if it's a, if
it's just a, if it's a comedy club,
they want it faster,
they want it quickly,
they want it smooth and I'm
not looking to hit the gags.
I'm just looking to find things
and have the space to stop and go.
What is it about cheese? Right.
Why is it got to ease in it?
I just want to waffle around until
I go. Okay, that, that's a good,
I'll keep that pit. Do
you ever feel like, uh,
like when you're doing
that like Jesus Christ,
I got to get off this fucking subject.
Like there's nothing there.
Well yeah I do that but then I do this
thing I write on my left hand like it's a
note to self and I go a bit. If I do
pig farmer talking about pigs and stuff,
they never talk about pig farming there.
You guys will pick firms. All right,
I'm not talking about it.
Never talking about cheese again.
Cheese jokes do not work. Especially
in North East London. You can,
you just get it, try and get lost
on the way out. The career is over.
Cheese is taking over my life. But, um,
do you do some gigs dressed in your
girl mode in some boring mode boy mode?
Or can I can,
I can do it whatever mode they want now.
It complete human torch thing.
I can fly so
I can wear a dress or I could wear
trousers and it doesn't matter.
And they don't give a monkey's
either. That's interesting. It's now,
well they're your fans. Yeah. Yeah.
Yes. It's that coming. Yeah. So,
uh, but I think get a disappointed
if he dresses as a man, um,
boy, girl mode. Um, they, uh,
I dunno. I don't care. I shouldn't care.
I can't be stage stage. Oh, I wonder,
cause because that's nothing to
do with the comedy. Yes. Yeah.
And I do think some people thought it was,
you know,
he's going to talk about lipstick for
two hours. So anywhere, another lipstick.
I know it was gross it at all. Do you
address it at all in your act diagonally?
I will do it diagonally. Diagonally, yeah.
Um, so it's never the front part of the,
the thing. Um, I will just say, uh,
uh,
what's a good day?
It would not be the front of the
subject. I might point in passing. Um,
so the, the front, I'll talk about
ancient king stuff with Banjos,
Doug's with fighting cats,
anything like that. And then I'm,
then I might mention it just in passing
as opposed to let me tell you about
being transgender. I just don't
do that. I talk about the fights.
I told about the fight I had,
which was a in the street and that this
guy was saying this and I said this.
And so we to either like I built a fight
into a huge thing if we stand off stuff.
So just I can make that
into, into something. But um,
no it's not cause it's supposed
to be the background of, uh,
of what I'm doing. The,
the essential thing,
if you'd like surreal comedy off
the wall comedy, that's what I do.
And I just happened to be transgender,
which makes no odds in these these days.
Do you find that more today than ever?
People are asking you questions about
transgender issues because they're,
they're at the forefront now. Less
action. Less. Yeah. Less real interesting.
There was a point early stage
of the spokesperson it was on
and they would, yes. Well,
um, if not a spokesperson,
I was someone who was
going to talk about it.
This chapter is all about this and I
do an interview and if it was an hour
interview, about 40 minutes would
be on the, on that and then,
and then when the Keto
writer, they thought, well,
I'm just writing all about this
transaction. All right, let's,
let's put that back a bit.
And then they used to balance it that
when they wrote the interview out. But um,
would you rather that they just
accept it and just not bringing it?
I'm fine with it. And I, I,
after the marathons, it'll,
it changed because they said,
oh,
so cause I used to say action transvestite
and executive transvestite. There was,
I was in New York, has played
New York and they said, um,
article a guy was found living in one
of the caves in the park in New York and
he finds that have a lot
of women's shoes in there,
so he's probably a
transvestite. And I went, okay,
well that's where they're transvestite.
I'm not living in a cave,
I'm traveling business
class on the plains.
This is executive transmits
that so I cannot with that one.
And then the action transvestite
was just kind of a fun,
cause I was more kind of Boise about
things that I'll give people grief in the
streets if they give me grief. And then,
uh, after the marathons it came, uh,
became a different thing and everyone
just went, oh, I've had some, you know,
I remember a guy,
this was a very interesting altercation
because hardly any words in it. So I'm,
I live near Victoria coach
station in London, um,
most of the time, whatever around. And I
was walking down there and then anyway,
it's a coach station,
so people are traveling all over the,
over the Europe from there.
And I walked out and I was in girl mode.
This guy looks at me and
said, hey, it is a ew, ew, ew.
On all those marathons. And you
were all that clubber, which all?
And then he went, yeah, yeah, yeah. And,
and it was just like he was getting me a
pass. He was going up. Well, okay. Okay.
Fab. Yeah. Well, I, that's
what my, I, you know,
I didn't have a negative opinion of you.
I had a positive opinion of you,
but my positive opinion of you elevated
once I saw you did those marathons.
My Dad's a person with an
iron will. That's a different
kind of like, you eat it.
It was so huge what you did
that everyone had to respect it.
Like they knew they couldn't do it, or if
they could do it, they haven't, you know,
that that action that's
covered. Yes. I haven't.
You accomplished something pretty
spectacular. It was beautiful. And it,
and I did about five things at once
and it was raising money. Yeah.
So I've think I've raised about four
and a half million pounds about I was 6
million, $700. So that feels great.
That's with their help because the
organization is good at raising the money.
And uh, it gave me this,
this, this confidence,
this health thing back from
when I was a kid. I used to be,
a lot of us were running
around you when you did that.
First one was I was 47.
So you're 47 and just
decided, yeah, I'm off.
Um, it was, it was training.
I wanted to do something. I,
it's an adventure as well and you know,
I think you have to live life as an
adventure, otherwise life is too hard.
But if you look at as eventually it means
the highs and lows built into it. Um,
and I, I got this, this
health kick out of it.
Um, uh, it was just a number of
that. And then I could meet people.
I remember on the first math and then
I met three army sergeants who were,
and they said, we've heard you're doing
this, some of the British army and what?
I was just having something
that we halfway through my,
what was it about my 10th
marathon? He said, we heard,
we heard you're doing this.
And, and, and there were
chatting to me and you know,
cause I know forces and I have that
mentality. I'm very happy to chat.
And suddenly I thought, wow, this is
an interesting respect thing. He said.
And they said, we're trainers, we train,
we work out the training
regimes for the army.
And so we were very interested in what
you're doing and what you seem to be able
to do. So they just found it fascinating.
And I found that fascinating.
I could suddenly talk to
service people in a certain way,
a sports people in a certain
way. It, everything just shifted.
And people from death,
different ethnic, uh, groups.
Some people have laid down
on some ethnic groups,
the down on being transgender or whatever.
But if you're doing that, then he says,
okay, we put these two together and
you want a different place. So it,
it has completely changed the
way a lot of people react to me.
Yeah. I can only imagine they don't
necessarily come to the comedy,
but that's fine because they respect you.
Yeah.
There's just certain different
things happen and uh, and you can,
and I'd like to chat to people.
I found that chatting is very important
because if you see someone and it's a
blog, make makeup, whatever, and you get
lipstick and you go, people can go Ooh,
but if you say hi, nice weather
today, and they go, ah, yes,
on a different footing and trying to
put you into a place of normalcy. Yeah.
Well I'm trying to put myself,
they will,
they will allow me indicating they will
allow me in. And it's normal. It is.
The talking is the most important thing.
Just chatting away and being boring.
I have a natural boringness. I think
maybe everyone has an awful boring this.
I think the really interesting people
probably just blow up and when they are
in their twenties and stuff because they
just do stuff that's too far out,
but most of us are pretty boring and
then we add layers of interestingness on
tops to to to reach that level of,
okay.
I think I'm quite interesting that I
think I've got enough interest in going on
a but my boring in chatting,
I am chatting and talking about whether
or wood or walls or trees or that
introduces the normalcy.
Yeah, the boring. I won't say,
I won't say we've got to
do something extreme now.
I'll just chat about yeah, normal thing.
Yeah. Where'd you get that jacket?
That's quite a good jacket on
you on. You woke up me, you know,
just just talk about things and B,
be human,
be a human being and she's the biggest
controversy in America in terms of
transgender people.
Probably the biggest or one of the
biggest is competing in sports with
biological women. That's
the biggest one. Yes.
If you're asking me for answers on
that, uh, haven't really got them.
I know. Yeah. I've got
one good one for, um,
for washrooms as you call
them. Lectures, restaurant,
which is on the urinals as you call them.
He called me rhinos.
Just check them all out and everyone just,
it's all cubicles.
And we already do that in restaurants.
We already share stuff. Uh, the, the,
the toilets in, right? We do it in
the airplanes. We have no bother.
If you just remove urinals at,
in theaters and places the won't be
carrying often than women are queuing
forever and the men are not
curing this way. Everyone shares,
everyone behaves around responsibility.
I've heard of it working in a school
as well. There's less bullying in,
in the lose. So it's the idea, just
check it's regression of technology.
I take it says get the wrong, check it
out the window. Everyone has a cubicle.
Just go to the loo and then use the
mirrors and, and, and then go at it.
It's just everything being for
both genders. You just make it all.
Even then we get outside
a lot of problems.
Some people will have pushed back on that
and have other reasons why they didn't
like it.
But women don't want to be in a washroom
with men though where they already are
going into. If they're sharing
it, they're losing the airplane.
If they're sharing it in a, yeah, but
a little airplane is one, you know,
it's only a strong person to go in there.
I think their concern is there's,
you know,
some men are fucking creeps and some
women just want to have a place where they
could just be themselves and check their
makeup and go to the bathroom and wash
and talk amongst other one. I understand
that it's just, I've, you know, um,
if you think about anything
that's going to change anything,
there's usually something that won't.
Wherever.
The only reason to do this
is to accommodate people
who are transgender in a way
that it seems like it doesn't, it doesn't
put them in a position where they,
they can be judged because
everyone's doing it. It makes, well,
if he stops bullying in
schools, then it's, it's,
it's a number of things in there
that, that, that it can make easier.
It just makes a whole,
whole area of things a lot easier.
How would it stop bullying? I don't
know what it has gone. I mean,
I'm just giving you the
figures kind. I said, well,
they just said that they tried it in
the school and the bullying went down.
She has his gills and his boys together
and it's like boys are bullied.
The boys or girls are believe
the girls, but if you, yeah.
So it's to have them all together.
They don't, it seems so now I,
it's just punished the creeps,
which is really what you, I mean,
if someone's being a creep in a bathroom,
that the problem is the creep.
It's not the bathroom. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. It's, um, anyway,
so this is a,
you know,
I haven't scientifically proved this
with chemicals and at a slide rule or
whatever,
but it's an idea that gets to us to
a better place and surely we're all
somewhere on the spectrum of
something. So the idea that, um,
that anyone who is expressing
themselves in a different way,
that that is a problem.
If you take it back just straight period.
If we all went back to how we used to
think that there was just men and women
and everyone had strikes,
sex, uh, even s that sex,
that when we talk about that people
Victorian Age, your quiver Victorian age.
Now when we're talking about that,
that was all horrible. Sex was a,
procreation was the whole
idea of everything. So if you,
I'm trying to get out to a practical
place where people just go to the loo and
behave like adults, even the kids
have to behave more like adults,
which is interesting. That
makes, that makes sense. I
see what you're saying. Yeah.
And me. Yeah. That is the
concern, right? Was it,
we have a system in place and
someone tries to change the system,
then people get upset that the trench and
that always happens. Yeah. I mean, uh,
but also women do queue forever and men
don't queue at all. Right. Q much less.
But this makes it so easy. It makes
it queuing even evens that out. So
like an at all.
It's just a toilet.
The Romans used to have it with
open plan toilets, then have a chat.
I've seen that we have
made it into a problem.
We have made this a
whole psychological brom,
whether I'm just sit down there
and have a pool and have a chat.
And once they did make it a problem
and categorize people by gender,
then it became this thing. And now you
don't want to change that. Well, yeah,
I don't think that they might've had
many male and female toys in the room at
times, but it just, the fact that
they were more open about the idea,
there's bodily functions and
just normal. And we've, you know,
back before we came in and we were just
going out into the woods and the forest
and having a pool and it was just
having a pool and now we feel it's a big
problem having a, we don't
like it, the fact we it,
but we don't want to admit that
we have the PR does the Queen,
they've have a poop.
Maybe Nafa has the attitude
be besides the marathon thing,
has the attitude culturally shifted in
the UK the same way it shifted in America
where people are more,
I think the more there's more and
more people are out and a positive.
I mean you've basically
got two from every group.
This is ethnic groups is from women.
This is from any one that,
that feels slightly out of the loop.
If you can have a pause,
any positive role models that go out
there that do other things, you know,
just something that's
nothing to do with sexuality.
You're very good at cooking
on television for this.
It tends to be television helps. Um,
you great sports star, you're this,
you're that.
Those things people say,
well there's a positive role model and
they are of a different color or of a
different sexuality or their,
you know,
and that just helps everyone
adjust their mindset.
And the younger people
come through and they, oh,
that's all they know and
know about this person.
I mean like you know in
baseball you see the Bait,
that famous documentary baseball,
the Ken Burns, Ken Burns one,
and that black people after the civil war,
black people were playing baseball.
And then there was some
guy who was very powerful.
He said there will be no black
people in major leagues at all.
And it was blocked from about
1890 something like this,
all the way through to 1950s so it was
actually happening and then it went
backwards. So there was a
positive role then. Well,
why over that happen?
Things can go backwards and things go
forwards and I just think if we're trying
to get to a world where everyone's
live in that live, yeah,
that's really what we need, right? It's
just live and let live live in that songs,
you're not interfering
with other people's lives.
You long as you're not doing something
that somehow or another fucks with
someone else. Like who cares?
Why would anyone care? I mean,
I think people care because
they're unhappy with themselves.
I think that's the only
time people care and let my,
my issue with this that I've
come across is with athletes.
It's with transgender athletes
competing against women,
particularly in my field and fighting.
Right. Um, there's been some,
there have been at least there was one
very vocal case when we're very public
case of a transgender athlete
who was a male for 30 plus years,
transitioned over for a couple of years,
for two years, and then started fighting.
Women didn't tell them that she used to
be a man and it became a giant issue and
people were outraged and anger.
The women who got beat up or angry cause
they got destroyed. Two of them did.
And then she started,
then she was public about it and then
started fighting women that were willing
and new.
You've got to say things upfront.
I came out that long ago because I wanted
to be up front about things. So yeah.
And I don't have the great answers. I've
been, I've balanced with everything.
But yeah,
I can see that.
One of the interesting things about
it is that there are no real answers,
that it's one of those things where you
just got to go home. What do we do here?
And this is,
this is what I think one of the more
unique things about being a person is that
we have this opportunity to look at this
unusual circumstance and communicate
about it and try to figure it out.
Communication, the whole thing.
I just knew my personal thing. If I came
out, if we started talking about it,
we'd get in a better place than not
talking about it and just saying it's a
negative. She came out to to give you a
feeling of relief. Unbelievable. I mean,
you know Skype, you know, cause you've
got the secret. And the secret is,
is I did self analysis. I lay on a bed
and said, why am I thinking this way?
What is going on? Why do I get them?
What are the thoughts? Like what, what?
Yeah. So I, okay, here's
the clearest way I can
show it. Uh, there was a woman on
television, you said, my daughter,
she was 12 and she was upstairs,
she was wearing my makeup,
she's wearing my heels and I told her to
get that stuff off. What are you doing?
She said to her daughter who's 12 and
that was from an age point of view and I
just thought, well that's what I'd be
doing at 12. That's what I was doing,
my stepmother's clothes and stuff.
So I thought well hang on,
I'm having exactly the same desire
to express myself in that way.
So I just wanted to express myself in
that way. And I was told like my society,
you're not allowed to. And I
just thought, well you know,
some people are allowed to and I'm not,
I've decided, I gave myself permission,
I said that I'm allowed to and
it's not hurting anyone else.
And I was stealing the makeup and after
that I started buying the record cause
the police got me,
he got caught stealing makeup and I go
back into the shopping Bexhill on and I
say, I used to buy this
lipstick. Thank you very much.
I think I probably say, yeah, it's him
again with a bloody lipstick. Um, so, uh,
yeah, it's, it's, you just had this
desire to express yourself in a way,
just like some women do and some
we've been done and somebody said,
I don't even wear any makeup, not going
to pay me. And I was not going to do it.
And if I had, if I look
very female, then I would,
I would, might wear different things
or express herself in a different way.
But I'm, I look kind of more
boyish, more male ish. So I,
I have to, you know, I choose
certain clothes at and look, um,
and I, and I do it that way and a number,
quite a lot of people are sort of going,
okay, fairplay that seems okay and
you're looking fairly well put together.
That's, that's what I get to.
So when you finally came out,
the relief though, did she could
just be yourself? Yeah. Just,
and you did, and you don't tend to look
terrible when you first come and you go,
well that doesn't work with that. Why
was I wearing that? That's correct.
But you've never had that teenage girl
chance to be able to try things out and
have your peer groups like you're
not wearing that cause that's okay.
So then I gradually led to,
okay, how does make it work?
Then how could that how it works?
So you gradually get better at things.
Don't buy that. That color doesn't work.
Oh, it can wait. But if you, you know, so,
but the relief is huge because you no
longer got this hellish secret and then
you can begin the dialogue.
I hadn't,
didn't really have a dialogue with anyone
at that point, but on stage I could.
I have friends that are in the closet
and they don't know what to do and they
even comedian friends that
they don't talk about it,
they hide it and I'm like,
God, if you just let it go,
I mean people in this day and age,
the people that will accept you,
that's the people you want anyway.
The people that don't accept you,
you don't want them like
that's their own problem.
It's this live and let live thing.
The people that don't want you to be
who you actually are to fit their own
narrative in their own head.
Like those people are the crazy
ones. It's not you. Yeah, it's
really obvious there are gay people.
It's really obvious they
were transgender people.
It's really obvious they're not,
no one's just making this stuff
back through history as well as forever.
And also I think I try,
I say quite often,
you know it's a genetic thing cause I
don't, I didn't feel like got out were,
you know when I was 23 and a half and
I said I think I've old become the old
transgender now. Yeah, no it was.
I was four or five when I first
knew it and it has not moved those,
those thoughts. That's interesting.
So I think it is for most gay,
lesbian people I've talked to, I just
think it's locked in. It's built in.
It's something you get
given these cards as I say,
and we're trying to be out front and
be positive and the express ourselves,
it only makes sense when you
look at the other variabilities,
the, the other variables when it comes to
people's personality, their body shape,
their mentality, their
drive, their ambition,
all these different variables.
It only makes sense that there's feminine
and masculine variables and that these
shifts back and forth with certain
people and it's certain people just like
there is somewhere in lake where you are,
well you have boy mode,
mode and grow mode and I,
I would imagine that you talking about
it so openly and then that you're,
that you're just so free with it that
there's probably people out there that are
listening to this. They're like, God damn
it. That's me, your host. I'm the young,
the youngest, uh, young
people around the world.
I have met people who are they
talking about it in school? Actually,
when I came back from South Africa, my
co writer, Kelly Jones, his, he said,
can you go in?
And my daughter's in Klaus and we'd been
talking about your runs in South Africa.
So I went in and they could talk about
racism because I was running a salute to
the Mandela 27. Matthew doesn't suit
his 27 years yet to spend in prison.
So they could talk about racism,
but they could also talk about being
trans transgender or self identifying and
LGBT stuff.
Cause there was some kid in this in the
class who was already identifying what
did I that if I as a girl and so they
were being positive and these kids were
eight I think, you know, so it's,
it's way different to our childhood,
our childhood.
It was just do not talk about duty and
if you mentioned that you're going to get
your head kicked in by your
peer group. So, and I was all,
that's why I never mentioned it
at school especially, you know,
I fancy girl so I could just
go in that route. And uh,
did you run into girls and
had an issue with it? Um,
people that I know less of.
But if you talk about relationships,
it gets really tricky because yeah, it
reflects upon people's relationships, uh,
with yourself. So, um,
but it's, it's cool.
And I've never, I've never been great
at relationships. That's always tricky.
So, well, you know,
if I got this career thing and I worked
at how I could work that and I can just
keep staying four steps ahead of the game
and I'm playing in all these countries,
the one doing the four
languages that, doing that. So
I've got all that. But then,
then had you,
you never really in one place to be able
to continue a ratio and then there's
that being transsexual and that goes on.
So that all gets complicated.
You can't be copied, get
everything working. No. So,
but I'm okay with that and
it's all good. And, uh,
and I enjoy things. I, I'll stage,
I try and make myself laugh.
This isn't uncommon. This is my trick. I
actually just try and live and I go, oh,
that's funny. So going off
of this, this weird trip, um,
uh, I'm going to tell you this, but
this is in later show in front of her,
but I talk about Jrr Tolkien,
I talk about the imagination.
We have written all these stories
and the animals haven't done that.
All the wild animals don't seem
to have written any stories.
I haven't heard of any good ones,
but we've written that Jrr Tolkien
and I say Jrr Tolkien, ar, ar,
ar talking was born,
Jay
r, r r, r, r, r, r
are talking, you may not know this
and people are gay. Is this true?
And it is born in bloom.
Bloemfontein South Africa, you know,
so he's got that and then they moved
to Birmingham in England and it's a
different axis of the significant next
morning that, and then beery booby comes,
we will look, this is to walk a dog
that was this kind of sound like this.
And then I said when he's five, he tends
to his mother because he realizes he's,
he's called
Jay Rrr, rrr, rrr,
Tolkien, and he says, and his
bird, it is South African,
Birmingham Trang and it goes both.
Both a we'll calls Volos.
I do this strangulated accent that it's
trying to fight between South African
and Bourbon. And it's such a
stupid line to go on, you know,
there's no logic to where I'm going. And
it's about as guy, what are you saying,
Jay? Odd, odd, odd icon, icons,
the standard and cause she's still in
South Africa and he's, he says you.
So I'm spending time going into the
sidebar, which is making me laugh.
And I think a lot of the audience are,
what is he, what is he wittering of that?
And you can't really even
hear what I'm saying,
but I just do this strangulated
accident and in the end he has to talk,
talking to Yorkshire accent too,
to get his mother to understand if you
could cut down the number of hours and
his name a becomes Jrr Tolkien.
So that's,
that's typical of my stand.
That where I just go off on a tangent
to make yourself laugh and yeah.
And I think it's sort of funny,
a little bit more funny for me.
Well it's funny for you though, it's funny
for people that are listening, we just,
comedy is contagious. Yeah. And if
I'm, you know, the personal state,
it's having a good time, then the audience
would probably have a better time.
And this thing of it's not being locked
down that it's living and breathing in
front of them. They do
love that. And uh, and,
and you put more energy into the next
bit when you go and then this and then
that and the other thing. Yeah. So I
do love standup cause it's, you know,
you can just do it and do it and you know,
there's no one,
when I was a double act, I wasn't
four person act. And whenever you,
if you're a double, even just a double
act, if you go off on a tangent,
then you have to look across to your
partner, your partner's going, hey,
where are you going?
He might want to go with it.
You might not want to go with
it gets keep to the script,
but on your own you could just go off.
And Lenny Bruce, you know the, the,
the gigs he did in front of the band.
Do you know that thing in the film,
that part of the film and he's trying
to make the band laugh and this is the
people, the raincoats in the
front and the Strip is coming on.
And because when we did the play,
Lenny,
we had a live actual jazz band on
the stage, a real good jazz musician.
So I was trying to make them laugh and
just the way that landing yet I would try
to crack them up cause I would
go off script and, and uh,
and I could do this and that was
just beautiful. And I, and they said,
you're riffing, aren't you? You're just
riffing like way roofing. And I thought,
Whoa, this is weird. This is,
it was really nice to cruise down
his life and do stand up as close,
closest as close to him as I could.
Even the mainstream.
I did the main more mainstream
stuff. And then, then, you know,
the really edgy stuff and
the weird stuff on the where,
where Jesus comes at the back and
you've got it. Pat's cathedral,
that whole sequence where he's got
the call, the Po call, the pokes.
Jesus is here and yeah,
that was fun.
Yeah.
I got very ill doing it.
Oh well you started off dead naked and
then you've got, you put your clothes on,
then you're talking and you start going
backwards. He starts off dead. Yeah.
You start off dead by.
So when he killed himself in the bathroom,
and then as you start and you're
talking to either God or, uh,
I think I'm talking to a judge who was
a bit like a god at the beginning of it
and explaining things and as I'm putting
my clothes on, so you start off naked,
then you have simulated sex with my wife,
but a quarter of the way through the film.
Um,
so that was interested in doing that and
then you end up dying at the end of the
film. So it just, it took a lot
out of me. Three months of that.
So emotionally,
emotionally and physically and I've
never been ill to out of a show,
but it just took me down.
I just was not well enough.
So you think it was just
contemplating his existence,
his life and what he went through?
I think, I think it was, yeah.
I think part of his journey and also
it was physically very grueling.
It is mentally and physically quite
very and mentally really grueling and
together that it made,
I was knackered and I probably just
wasn't drinking of water. I should have,
you know, I tend to
think, um, this is a, uh,
me trait definitely that I will
just carry on until I get ill.
I wouldn't necessarily think, okay,
you're going into a stress period now,
so let's get some good water on.
It's eat some healthy food and so that
nothing comes in and takes you out.
I just didn't think it was a bold,
those are where I tend to boulders.
We just bulldoze through three hours.
Three yeah,
it's three o'clock o'clock there. Yeah.
I was thinking I'd have no idea how long.
The crazy, yeah. It's like a time warp in
here. Well then you're, you're, you're,
you're good at it. You're used to it. I,
I once did a street show for
about two hours without starting,
which was quite a beautiful
cars on the street.
If you imagine that there's no
nothing and the festivals, you know,
they hadn't before.
And there's this place called the mounds,
so there's people milling around.
So I was almost starting a show and I
was just mucking about for two hours.
I was just there kind of not starting,
kind of starting kind of chat and kind
of playing around. Beautiful. It's,
I've done the most fun things on the
street because no one's in charge of
anything. There's just no rules. Yeah.
I, I seen Dave Chappelle do that.
Dave Chappelle did that in Montreal.
We
were doing a sub club soda and then
he came downstairs after we did a,
I think he was like 18 or 19 and just
took his hat off and started doing standup
and had people put money in the hat I
was doing stand up on the street that it
was pretty wild. Pretty free. I see. You
see in Washington Square Park? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That's, um, Charlie
Burnett was famous for that.
Charlie Burnett was a guy who was a,
one of the original street standup comics
in New York and he would do that and
Washington square park
and gather everyone round.
There's video of it that
people could watch online.
He might, I think he went to,
he might've come over to
England at one point did he?
I think he might have a very, he
was brilliant, brilliant performer.
Really good at grabbing
people and grabbing their
attention and Dave learned a
lot from him. Eddie, thank you very
much, man. Thanks a lot of fun.
I really enjoyed it.
I'm really appreciate you coming here
that we got the chance to sit down.
Absolutely.
I tell people about your tour a where
they can find where you're going to be
tickets, all that jazz. He is
a.com that sweats happening.
I and I am next two and a half
months all the way up to mid July.
I'm around,
so a 40 cities,
40 cities in America already
played all 50 states,
which is kind of beautiful. You played
Montana. I've played everywhere.
What'd you go on? Montana? Uh, uh, I'm not
sure. What's the capital city? Billings,
I think, yeah. I think we play billings,
if not the only near Bozeman. Helena.
Is that it? Yeah. What about Wyoming? He
did Wyoming. Yeah. All of them. I'm, yeah,
I made a point to ask a twice.
Wow. We ended up in Hawaii,
but every single one in clear Mississippi
and Alabama as well. That's awesome. Um,
so, uh, everywhere, but it's, it's
nice. It's, I just love playing,
you know, I just love playing around the
world onward. Yeah. Good luck to you.
Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate you.
Thank you.